hey welcome to draft academy my name is
mike in this course i'm going to be
teaching you guys everything you need to
know to get started in the c programming
language c is an awesome programming
language and it's actually one of the
oldest programming languages around in
fact a lot of modern programming
languages are based off of c so it's a
really good idea if you want to get into
c or even if you're trying to get into
something like c plus plus to learn the
basics and in this course we're going to
cover everything you need to know i'm
going to talk to you guys about
installing a text editor and using the c
compiler and we're gonna write some
basic code i'll talk to you guys about
you know what is a program and how do
programs work and how does c
uh read the instructions that you give
it and we're gonna get into some more
advanced stuff we're gonna look at
things like if statements and loops
we're going to create different
variables we're going to talk about the
different types of data that you can use
and see then we're going to get more
advanced we're going to talk about
things like structures and functions
we're going to talk about pointers and
basically i'm just going to give you a
full overview of all of the core
concepts in c so by the end of this
course you'll have a really good
understanding and a really good
foundation which you can build on you
can kind of go forward and learn some
more i'm really excited to be bringing
you guys this basic course on c i'm
really excited for you guys to dive in
and start using these tutorials so feel
free to click around through all the
videos and hopefully you'll learn
something awesome about c
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about getting everything set up
to start programming in c
now in order to program in c we're
actually going to need two things the
first thing we're going to need is an
environment where we can write our c
programs now there's a bunch of these
different environments essentially all
you need is just a text editor so
anything that can you know allow you to
write text and then save that text in a
specific file format is going to work
although when we're working with c a lot
of times it can be useful to use a
special environment called an ide
and ide stands for integrated
development environment basically this
is a special text editor which makes it
a lot easier for us to write our c
programs in so i'm going to show you
guys how to install an ide called code
blocks the second thing we need to write
our c programs is going to be something
called a c compiler now c is a
programming link which means we can
basically write out you know
instructions that we want to give to the
computer but eventually for the computer
to be able to execute those instructions
they have to be compiled which basically
means like translated or transformed
into a language that the computer can
understand so we're going to basically
download and install a special program
that will do that for us so let's get
started i'm going to come over to my web
browser
and i'm just going to go up to the
google search bar and i'm going to
search for a program called code block
so just type in
code blocks c
and this link should come up it's
codeblocks.org
now this is an integrated development
environment it's basically a text editor
that will make it really easy for us to
write our c programs so i'm going to
come down here into downloads
and there's a bunch of options here one
says download the binary release
download the source code we want to
click on download the binary release
this is going to be the easiest option
so if you're on windows or linux or mac
you can install it from this page so
depending on the operating system that
you're on you want to click that i'm on
windows so i'm going to come down here
to the windows option you'll see there's
little options for us to download this
stuff
so
there's a bunch of options here what we
want to download is going to be this one
right here it says code blocks
and then the version number and then it
says
min gw hyphen setup
basically what this is it's going to
allow us to install code blocks so we're
going to be able to install that ide
program and we're also going to be able
to install a c compiler so remember i
said we needed those two programs we
needed those two things and this is
actually gonna give us both of them on
windows so i'm gonna come over here and
click on the link to download this from
sourceforge.net and you can see it's
gone ahead and downloaded that so now
let's head over to our downloads folder
and i'm just going to double click on
this setup program so this should open
up a window where we can set up the
program and let's just click through
this so i'm just going to click next i'm
going to agree to the license and
basically just leave all the options as
default and you should be good to go all
right when that's done installing it's
gonna ask us to run code blocks so we
can just go ahead and do that and it's
giving me this little window here it
says compilers auto detection
so you can just click on the one up here
that's highlighted it says gnu gcc
compiler and i'm just going to click set
as default and click ok
and there you go we now have code blocks
installed
so in the next few tutorials we're going
to be learning about setting up code
blocks writing our first c programs and
really just getting started with c but
for now you have everything you need to
get started
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about getting everything set up
to start programming in c on os x so if
you're using a mac then this video will
basically show you how to get everything
set up in order to start working with c
we're actually going to need two things
the first thing we're going to need is a
text editor basically we're going to use
the text editor to write our c programs
in and you can use any text editor that
you want to write c programs but there's
actually a special type of text editor
which is called an ide and it stands for
integrated development environment and
it's basically a special environment
where we can go to
write and run and manage our c programs
so that's the first thing the second
thing we're going to need is what's
called a c compiler now c is a
programming language so essentially what
we're doing when we're using it is we're
writing instructions for the computer
but in c we're writing instructions that
us humans can understand and work with
but in order for the computer to be able
to carry them out they have to be
compiled or translated or transformed
into a language that the computer can
understand and that's what the c
compiler is going to do it's going to
take our c programs and essentially just
translate them into a language that the
computer can understand
so the first thing i'm going to do is
show you guys how to install that
compiler and then we'll get a text
editor
so what you want to do on your mac is go
over to the search bar and you're just
going to type in
terminal
and click enter and a window that looks
like this should pop up now the terminal
is basically a program that allows us to
interact with the computer using text
commands so we're actually going to need
to use the terminal in order to do what
we want to do
so first thing we want to do is check to
see if you might already have a c
compiler installed so in certain
circumstances you might already have one
so you just want to type in cc
hyphen v and click enter
and you'll see over here i have a c
compiler installed so i'm getting all of
this information you can see over here
it says like ceiling
and it's giving me you know a bunch of
information
if you have that then you have your c
compiler installed and you're ready to
go
but if you don't have that i'm going to
show you guys how to get it so all you
want to do is just type in
xcode
select and then space hyphen hyphen
install
and click enter and you'll see i'm
getting an error here because i already
have these command line tools installed
but if you don't already have them
installed and obviously then you
wouldn't have that c compiler then this
is going to go off and install
everything you need to get that c
compiler working so
once you've run that xcode select
command just
type in cc hyphen v again and you should
be getting this version number
all right so now that we have our c
compiler installed what we want to do is
download an ide so we want to download a
special text editor that we can use to
write our c programs in so i'm going to
go over here to my web browser and i'm
up here at a website called
codeblocks.org and this is an ide called
codeblocks it's one of the most popular
free
ides for programming in c so we're just
going to come down here to this
downloads link
and there should be a few options here
download the binary release download the
source code we're going to click
download the binary release
and you'll see down here we have a bunch
of options for windows linux and mac
click the mac option and if we come down
here you'll see that here is what we
need to install code blocks on mac so if
you go over to the right side here
there's a link to sourceforge where we
can download it so just click that link
and it should start downloading
automatically when that finishes
downloading let's head over to our
downloads folder and you'll see here we
have our zip file so i'm just going to
double click on this
and this should give us code blocks now
all you want to do is just drag and drop
code blocks into your applications
folder and you're ready to go so you
have code blocks installed and ready to
start following along with this course
and writing some awesome c programs
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about getting our first c file
set up so we're going to load up a c
file and we're going to be able to get
everything working and test out our
program so i'm going to open up my code
blocks program and this is the ide that
i'm going to be using for the rest of
this course so i'm just going to double
click on it and it should start opening
once we have code blocks open you'll see
over here there's a bunch of different
options like create a new project open
an existing project so we're actually
going to want to create a new project so
whenever we're going to start writing
some c files we're going to want to
create a new project in code blocks so
you can either click this button right
here or you can go up to file
new
and project so either way it's going to
bring you to this window over here
and this there's going to be a bunch of
options here basically just uh these are
different types of like c projects that
we could create what we're going to be
doing is creating a console application
this is like just a basic c project that
you could run on your computer that's
exactly what we need so click on console
application and then click go and i'm
just gonna click through this wizard and
you'll see over here it says uh c plus
plus or c
now c and c plus plus are both uh
different programming languages for this
course we're gonna be working with c so
just highlight c and click next and
we're gonna give this a title i'm just
gonna call mine draft
and we're gonna have to put this project
inside of a folder so i'm gonna open
this up and i'm just going to put this
on my desktop so let's click ok
and click next and you can leave all of
these options as the default and we'll
click finish so now what we should have
is our first c project in code blocks
now over here inside this little file
explorer you'll notice that draft is
right here so that was the name of the
project that i just created down here we
have this source folder so i'm going to
click down and you'll see we have this
file here called main dot c and this is
a file that got automatically created
for us by code blocks i'm just going to
right click and open it and you'll see
over here we have some default code so
up here there's these little lines of
code that say include down here this
says int main so this is the program
that we're given by default when we
created our c project and this is sort
of like the simplest c program that you
can write essentially what this program
does is it prints out hello world onto
the screen so in order to run this
program and test it and just make sure
that everything's working i'm going to
come up here and you'll see that there's
this green play button over here and it
just says run when i hover over it when
i click this button this file that we
have open right here main.c is going to
get run so we're essentially telling
codeblocks to run this file and execute
the program so when i click the run
button we're getting this message it
says the project hasn't been built yet
do you want to build it click yes and
now over here this little window pops up
basically this is the command prompt so
whenever i run a c program this little
window is going to pop up so if i was to
exit out of this and run this program
again
you'll see this window pops up again and
it basically just executes the program
and in the case of this program all
we're doing is we're printing out
hello world onto the screen that's
actually what this instruction does over
here when we open up this command prompt
it's essentially just executing the
program and it's printing out whatever
we told it to print out so it's printing
out hello world over here and printing
something out onto the screen is really
easy and that's one instruction that we
can give to the computer but as we go
through this course we're going to learn
all sorts of instructions that we can
use but the purpose of this tutorial was
just to get our c project set up and to
test our main dot c file so as long as
everything worked here and you're good
to go and now we can start really
learning how to program in c
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about the basics of writing a
program in c so if you've been following
along with the course up to this point
we've installed a text editor we've
installed a c compiler and we set up our
first c program our first c project
inside of codeblocks so now essentially
what we have is this file over here this
is that main dot c file i just kind of
want to point out a couple things that
are in here first up here we have these
little instructions which are just
called include and i'm not going to get
too much into what those do in this
tutorial later on in the course we're
going to talk about what these are
actually doing and the specifics of you
know how they're helping our program but
for now just know that in order for us
to use our program we're going to need
to have these guys up there
next thing we have is this little block
of code called main
and it just has this name main you can
see there's an open and closed
parentheses and this is actually what's
called a
method and don't worry too much about
what methods are we're gonna again we're
gonna talk more about those in future
but essentially a method is just like a
container where we can put some of our
code
and this method main is very important
because this is the method that's going
to get executed when we run our program
so in c we can actually write out a
bunch of instructions for the computer
and then we can run our program so we
can tell the computer to execute those
programs and whenever the computer
executes our c program it's going to
look inside of this main method in other
words it's going to look inside of all
the code inside of these open and close
curly brackets and it's going to execute
that code so i have this instruction
here it's called printf and basically
this is just printing out some text onto
the screen when we run our program it's
going to come into this main method and
it's going to execute all the
instructions inside of here namely this
printf method so if i was to run my
program then this is going to work now
let's talk about actually running a
program whenever we want to run a
program that we write and see we
actually have to do two things the first
thing we have to do is what's called
building a program or compiling a
program and basically what that does is
it takes all of this c code and it
translates it into a language that the
computer is going to be able to
understand and execute so it's
essentially taking this c program code
translating it into computer code and
then the computer can execute it and run
our program so the first thing we have
to do is always build our c file the
second thing we have to do is run the
file that gets built
so once we've built this program we've
compiled it down into code the computer
can understand we have to run it
basically tell the computer to execute
that code and in code blocks it's
actually really easy to do this so we
can come over here and this little gear
icon will allow us to build our program
and then this play button will allow us
to run our program but a lot of times
when you're programming you're going to
want to build and run your code at the
same time right you're just going to
want to build it and run it just to see
what happened you know see how your
program did so we have this option over
here called build and run and this will
both build your program and run it at
the same time so generally as you're
going through this course you're going
to want to be using this option this
build and run options when i click this
it'll essentially build my program run
it and then it'll show up here on this
little window and this little window is
basically a console window you could
call it so a lot of people would refer
to this as the console
and it'll just like output any
information that we tell it to so if we
write a c program that doesn't output
information that doesn't print anything
to the screen then we wouldn't actually
see this but since we're using this
printf command that window is going to
pop up so let's talk about how these
programs actually get executed
essentially when we write a program we
have a set of instructions so when i'm
writing a c program i'm basically
writing out a set of instructions
imagine you were writing like a recipe
or something right a recipe is
essentially just a set of instructions
that when executed correctly will result
in you know cooking or baking something
delicious right and that's basically
what these c programs are it's a set of
instructions that when executed
correctly will result in the computer
doing something for us and one of the
cool things about computers is that we
can program them to do anything and c is
one of the best languages to do that
with so let's look at this instruction
over here it's called printf and like i
said this prints something out onto the
screen but you'll notice over here at
the end we have this semicolon and this
semicolon is actually really important
so whenever we write an instruction in c
we always want to end it off with a
semicolon that tells c that we're done
with that instruction and we want to
move on to the next one so i could
actually copy this instruction
and i could paste it down here
and now we're basically going to be
executing this instruction twice so if i
was to run and build my program you'll
see that we're not only printing it out
once but we're also printing it out
twice so when we run our program the
program comes down into this main method
and it looks at all the instructions
inside of it so it starts with this
first instruction it executes it right
so it prints out hello world onto the
screen and then it also prints out a new
line so this backslash n is like a new
line character and that'll move the text
onto a new line when it's done with this
instruction it moves on to the next
instruction and it'll execute that
instruction so as we go forward and we
learn how to write and see we're going
to learn more and more complex
instructions we'll be able to use all
those instructions in conjunction with
each other to specify some seriously
complex programs but for now this is
really the only instruction that we know
which is printf so why don't we use this
printf instruction in order to
draw out a little shape onto the screen
so i'm going to show you guys how we can
draw out like a little triangle onto the
screen
i'm going to take this printf
and i'm actually just going to get rid
of hello world
and i'm going to copy this a couple
times so i'm just going to copy it and
we'll paste it down here maybe four
times
and what i can do is i can specify
instructions to the computer that will
tell it to draw out a particular shape
so down here i could make like a forward
slash and over here we'll make another
one
and i'll make another one and i'll make
another one and you can see here i've
drawn like a little diagonal line with
these forward slashes now i'm going to
draw vertical bars going all the way
down so i'm going to put one here
i'm going to put one here
i'll put one here
and finally why don't we draw some
underscores and then we'll put one so
i'm basically drawing out a little
triangle shape and these backslash ends
are just printing out a new line so
anytime i print this it's going to move
it onto a new line so it'll print this
guy out now on the line down the line
below so if i was to save my program and
execute it now the computer is going to
go through it's going to execute each
one of these instructions in order and
we'll be able to print out the shape
onto the screen so let's do that you see
over here we get our shape
and
one thing i really want to stress is
that order matters so if i took this
instruction
and i placed it up here
as the first instruction now this is
going to get printed out first so when i
run my program you'll see that we're
printing out this kind of funky looking
shape and that's because we changed up
the order of the instructions so the
computer changed the order in which it
executed those instructions
and you'll notice here again we're using
this semicolon after each line of code
so that's kind of the basics of writing
a program that's essentially all you
need to know when we're writing a
program we're specifying a list of
instructions that we want the computer
to carry out and depending on which
instructions we give the computer and
which order we give them and how complex
the instructions are that'll determine
what the program does and as we go
through this course we're going to learn
more and more complex instructions we're
also going to learn how we can take
simple instructions like printf and do
different things with them to make our
programs a lot more powerful
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about variables in c
now when we're using c programming
language a lot of times we're going to
be dealing with data so there's going to
be different data values or different
information that we're going to want to
keep track of and use
inside of our programs and sometimes it
can be difficult to maintain and keep
track of all that data and that's where
variables come in a variable is
essentially a container where we can
store different pieces of information so
different data values we could sort
things like numbers or text or
characters and these variables make it a
lot easier for us to keep track of and
manage all the data in our program so
i'm going to show you guys basically how
variables can be useful and how we can
use them in our c programs down here i
have a very basic program i'm basically
just printing out a little story it says
there once was a man named george
he was 70 years old he really liked the
name george but did not like being 70.
so this is a simple program we're just
printing out a bunch of different lines
of text and then when i run this program
you'll see we print out the actual story
so over here we have our story and this
is great but let's say that i'm reading
through my story i'm reading through my
program and i'm thinking to myself hmm i
think i want to change the character's
name so instead of calling the character
george why don't we call him like john
in order to make that change i'm gonna
have to look through my entire program
and find every place where we mentioned
the character's name so right here is
one change it to john i'm gonna have to
keep looking and here's another one so
we'll change this to john right so i had
to manually go through and change every
instance of the character's name to john
and let's say that okay that sounds
pretty good but maybe i'm thinking i
want to make the character a little bit
younger so instead of 70 why don't we
make him 35. so now again i'm gonna have
to look through my entire program find
every place where we mention the
character's age and change it to 35.
so there and there there you go i
changed the program i updated i modified
it now if i was to run this program then
all that information will be updated and
we'll have our new story here's the
problem though i'm dealing with a very
short story i mean this is four lines we
only mentioned the character's age and
name twice but imagine if i was writing
out a huge c program that had hundreds
of lines in this story so this story had
hundreds of lines and maybe we mentioned
the character's name hundreds of times
we mentioned their age hundreds of times
well if i wanted to change the
character's age or name i would have to
go through and manually change it in
every single location that would take
forever and it would be a huge drag
basically that's not a good way for us
to manage and maintain the data in our
programs right we basically have two
pieces of data that we're working with
consistently in this program the
character's age and the character's name
what i want to show you guys now is how
we can use variables to better keep
track of and manage these pieces of
information
so remember a variable is basically just
a container where we can store some data
so i want to create two variables which
will store the character's name and the
character's age and i'll show you guys
how this can make our program a lot
easier to manage
up here above these print statements i'm
just going to make a new line and i'm
going to come over here and i want to
create a variable now whenever we create
a variable in c we have to give c a
couple pieces of information so we have
to basically tell c a couple different
things the first thing we have to tell c
is what type of information we want this
variable to store now i'm going to get
into the different data types that we
can represent and see more in the next
tutorial but for now just know that
there's a bunch of different types of
data that we can store and see we can
store things like numbers characters we
can store text we can store decimal
numbers all sorts of stuff like that in
our case i'm going to store the
character's name and the character's
name is basically just a collection of
characters so in order to create this
variable the first thing i have to do is
tell c that i want to create a variable
that's going to store characters so to
do that i'm just going to type out char
just like that
and that'll basically tell c hey we're
going to store characters inside of this
variable
after we type out char i want to type
out the name of the variable that i want
to create remember a variable is a
container and it's a good idea to give
these containers descriptive names and
those names will basically let us know
what that variable is storing inside of
it so i'm going to call this
character name and now what i want to do
is i basically want to store multiple
characters so over here i'm telling c
that i want to store a character but in
c we can also store instead of just
storing like one single character we can
store a bunch of characters and that
would be kind of like you know a name so
there's like four characters in here
in order to store a bunch of characters
inside of this variable after we type
the character the variable's name we're
going to have to make an open and closed
square bracket and that's going to tell
c that we want to store a bunch of
characters inside this variable
so i'm going to type char character name
open and close square brackets i'm going
to set this equal to something so i'm
essentially assigning a value to this
variable and i'm just going to make an
open and closed quotation marks and
inside of here we're going to type out
the value that we want to store so in my
case i'm just going to store the
character's name which is john and then
as always in c we're going to have to
end this off with a semi-colon
all right so essentially what i did here
was i created a variable and i told c
what i wanted to store in the variable i
wanted to store a character i gave this
variable a name it was character name
and i used these open and closed square
brackets to sell c that i wanted to
store a bunch of characters not just one
now what we can do is we can make
another variable to store the
character's age so in this case we're
going to want to do something similar
but we're going to want to store a
number there's a bunch of different ways
that we can store numbers and see but
for our purposes we're storing a name so
we're going to use something called an
integer and an integer is basically just
a whole number so i'm just going to type
out int
and that basically stands for integer
and now we're going to give this a name
so i'm going to call this
character age
and i'm going to set this equal to a
number so in our story the character is
35 so i'm just going to type out 35 and
now we can again end this off with a
semicolon so i have two variables here
this one's storing a collection of
characters this one's storing an integer
now the question becomes how can we use
these inside of our program well
basically what we can do is we can print
them out alongside of this text and we
can actually use this print f
instruction in order to do that so i'm
going to show you guys how to do this
and then we're going to talk about it so
basically i'm going to go over here
where we have the character's name i'm
going to erase this and i'm going to
replace it with a percent sign and an s
and now over here i'm going to make a
comma and i'm just going to type in the
variable name so i'm going to type in
character name
and basically what's happening is when
we use this percent s we're telling c
that inside of this string of text here
we're going to want to insert
another string and a string is basically
just a collection of characters so i
could call this up here a string
variable so when i say percent s this is
basically a placeholder and i'm telling
c i'm going to insert a string into here
and over here i use this comma and then
i type out the string that i want to
include so in our case it's character
name and so basically over here it's
going to say there once was a man named
percent s and it's going to replace
percent s with whatever we specify over
here so it's going to replace percent s
with the value that's stored inside that
character name variable so i'm going to
save this and we'll run our program
and now you'll see that it's still
printing out there once was a man named
john
even though we didn't actually type out
john over here we just typed percent s
in the character name so i can do this
in this other spot too so down here
we're also using the character's name so
i can type percent s
and over here we can type
character name and again this is going
to act as a placeholder for this string
of characters that we specify over here
let's do the same thing with the age so
over here we have the age is 35 i'm
going to do something similar i'm going
to say percent
but now because i have a number instead
of using percent s i'm going to use
percent d
and that basically means that we're
going to insert an integer number into
here so i'm saying he was percent d
years old and over here i'm going to
make a comma and i'm just going to type
out the name of the variable that i want
to be placed inside of here so i'm just
going to be
character age and we're going to do this
one more time down here i'm going to
type percent d
and
character age so essentially what i'm
doing is i'm printing out the value
that's inside of character age where i
specify this placeholder so
let's go ahead and run our program and
now you'll see it's going to look
exactly the same as it did before it's
the same story the same name and the
same age except i didn't have to
actually type out the character's age
and the character's name inside the
story i just referred to the variable
and what's cool about variables is i
could come up here and let's say i
wanted to modify the character's age
all i would have to do is modify it in
this one spot so we could change the
character's a name to like tom and we
could also change their age to like 67
and now when i run my program all of
that's gonna get updated in the story so
now it's using the name tom
and the age of 67. in our case we only
mentioned the character's name and the
character's age a couple times but you
can imagine if i was mentioning this
variable like 10 or 20 or 30 times
having to change it in each one of those
individual spots would be extremely
difficult so variables are great because
we can store the value one time and then
if we want to modify it we just modify
it in one place so another cool thing
that we can do with these variables is
we can actually modify them so let's say
that halfway through the story i wanted
to change the character's age i could
actually come down here i can make a new
line and right above these print
statements i could give this variable a
new value so i could say
character age and i can just set it
equal to something else so we can set it
equal to like 30. and again we want to
include that semicolon so now halfway
through the story the character's age is
actually going to change so you'll see
it says there once was a man named tom
he was 67 and then down here the age is
being 30. so we actually modified the
value that was stored inside of the
variable halfway through printing out
our story and that's really why
variables are useful so that's kind of a
basic overview and introduction into
what variables are why they're useful
how we can use them and over here again
we're storing a collection of characters
which is called a string and we're also
storing this integer but there's uh some
other data types that we can also
represent so in addition to representing
like a string or a number we can do some
other stuff as well and i'm going to
talk about that in the next video but
for now this has just been a basic
overview and introduction into variables
in c
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about data types in c now in the c
programming language we're going to be
dealing with a lot of data so generally
when you're writing programs you're
going to be dealing with all sorts of
information and in this tutorial i just
want to talk to you guys about
what types of information we can
represent and use
inside of our c program and these are
called data types right so what are the
different types of data that we can work
with in our program so i'm going to show
you guys all those different data types
right now so a lot of times in c when
we're working with data we're going to
be storing that data inside of variables
so i'm just going to show you guys a
bunch of different variables that we can
create and all the different types of
data that we can store inside of those
variables so remember whenever we create
a variable in c we have to tell c a
couple pieces of information and the
first piece of information we need to
tell c is what type of data that we want
to store inside of that container inside
of that variable so let's talk about the
different types of data one of the most
basic types of data and probably one of
the types of data you're going to be
using the most is going to be numbers
there's actually two very important
types of numbers that we can represent
in c
so the first type is called an integer
and an integer is basically a whole
number so it's a counting number right
if i was counting on my fingers one two
three four five i'm just counting out
whole numbers and i'm not saying like
one one and a half to 2.3 like i'm
counting in whole numbers and that's
what an integer is so to create an
integer we could just say int and we'll
give this a name so we could say like
age and we could set age equal to like
40 or something now whenever we want to
use an integer in c we always just want
to type out the number so you'll notice
i'm not putting quotation marks or
parentheses or anything around this i'm
just typing out the number like that and
now we actually have our variable age
another type of number we can create is
a decimal number so this would be a
number unlike an integer so it would be
like 2.5 or 8.67 or
7.538 right it's a number that has a
decimal point associated to it so
there's actually two types of decimal
numbers in c there's something called a
double and there's something called a
float and i'm not going to get too much
into the difference between the two of
them but as a beginner to see for the
most part you're just going to want to
use a double so i'm just going to type
out double and this could be like
someone's gpa for example it might be
like a 3.7
or whatever so you know you can use the
double to represent decimal numbers it's
also important to note that i could also
represent like the number three so i
could just say like 3.0 and that's going
to be a decimal or i could say 40.0
so the difference between 40 and 40.0 is
that 40.0 is a double it's a decimal
number and 40 without the decimal point
is an integer so that's something just
to keep in mind so you can make this
like 3.6 so those are the two basic
types of numbers integers and doubles
and those are going to come in handy all
the time now the next type of data that
we're going to want to store is going to
be characters so in c we can store
single characters inside of a variable
so i could just say c-h-a-r and that
stands for character and we could give
this a value so maybe it'd be like
someone's grade and when we create a
character in c we're basically going to
specify the character that we want to
store inside of single quotation marks
so inside of these single quotation
marks i could put a letter i could put
like a or lowercase a we could put h
c
d
f basically you can put any character
that you want to store so if i put an a
here now this character variable grade
is going to store the single character a
inside of it it's important to note that
you can only store one character so i
couldn't put like a whole bunch of
characters over here that's actually
gonna throw an error all we can do is
store one single character
but these three are the basic data types
in c so these are the basic types of
information that we can deal with in our
c programs and just using these three
data types we can represent all sorts of
information i also want to talk to you
guys about one sort of extra data type
and it's not technically a data type in
c it's technically like a modification
of the character data type
so you notice when we create a character
we can only store one letter one single
character inside of it but a lot of
times we're going to want to represent
more than one character so we're going
to want to represent like a string of
characters and generally this is called
a string so it's a collection of
characters that are grouped together and
we can use this char data type in order
to create a string so i can basically
say char i can type out the name of the
string that i want to create so i could
say like phrase and then after this i
can make an open and closed square
brackets and this is basically going to
tell c that we want to string a bunch of
characters together and what we're
actually doing is creating something
called an array and i'm going to get
into arrays later in the course but just
for now know that we can create a string
of characters by using char
specifying the name these open and close
square brackets and then we can create
this using two open and closed quotation
marks so instead of these single quotes
up here we're just going to use double
quotes and i could type in like a phrase
so i could type in whatever string of
text i want here and this will get
stored inside of this variable which
like i said is technically called an
array now it's important to note that
doing something like this so creating
this like string of characters is a
little bit different from these guys up
here so like these variables up here we
could modify them we could give them new
values but you can't do stuff like that
with this so just know that this is like
a special type of data and it's going to
act a little bit differently than these
ones up here but that's sort of the
basics of working with data and those
are all the basic data types that we're
going to be using in our c programs
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys some more about the printf function
so if you've been following along with
this tutorial we've been using an
instruction in our c programs called
printf and printf basically allows us to
print different things out onto the
screen in this tutorial we're going to
talk more about what printf does we're
going to look at how we can use it to
print out things like variables and also
things like different data like numbers
and strings and all that stuff
so in order to use printf we just type
out p r i n t f and we're gonna make an
open and closed parentheses and a
semicolon now printf is what's called a
function basically what that means is it
performs a specific task or a specific
function
in our case printf just prints something
out onto the screen right the task that
it's doing is printing something out and
it basically works how you'd expect it
to work so if i came in here i could
print out a specific piece of
information and generally when we're
using printf we're going to be printing
out text so i can make an open and
closed quotation marks and i could print
out like hello world in here now this
will print out onto the screen
hello
and inside of printf i can use all sorts
of special characters so if i wanted to
create a new line for example i can make
a backslash n and down here i could type
world and now this will print out a new
line so you'll see hello world on
different lines
we can also use these special characters
so for example i could print out like a
quotation mark so if i just printed a
normal quotation mark right here you'll
notice that it's messing this up so it's
sort of like counting this as the entire
string
if i wanted to change that i can just
put a backslash here and now this will
literally render a
quotation mark so when i run my program
you can see we have a quotation mark
there
and so that's kind of like the basic
usage right you can specify some text
that you want to print out onto the
screen and it'll do it but this printf
function is actually extremely powerful
and we can use it to print out different
pieces of information so in addition to
just printing out plain text inside of
these quotation marks i could also print
out other types of information for
example i could print out a number
and if i wanted to print out a number i
would have to use something called a
format specifier the format specifier
basically tells this printf function
that we want to print out a type of data
that's not just plain text like this
so if i said percent sign and then i
said d
this would actually allow me to print
out a number so generally when we use
these format specifiers uses percent
sign and that tells c that you're going
to want to print out something special
and then after that we would type in a
specific letter and that will tell c
what exactly we want to print out so if
i said percent d
this means that we want to print out an
integer so
all i have to do now is i can make a
comma and over here
i can specify the integer that i want to
print out so i could say like 500 and
now this is going to print out 500 to
the screen so you can see over here
we're getting 500. and this is cool
because we can interweave these
different types of data with text so i
could say like
my favorite number is
percent d and this acts as a placeholder
for this number over here so when i run
my program now it says my favorite
number is 500 and that's really cool
we can also use multiple format
specifiers so in addition to just using
this percent d i could also specify
another one so over here i could say
percent s
and you'll notice that this is
structured similarly to percent d
percent s is basically going to allow us
to include some text so i can include
some more text just like this so if i
said percent s i can make another comma
here and i could say
number
and now this is going to print out my
favorite percent s so it's going to look
for this string of text over here it's
going to insert that in and it's going
to say 500. so now when we run this
it'll say my favorite number is 500. and
you'll notice here that i'm using
multiple commas so i'm saying like
percent s percent d
and over here i have a comma and i'm
specifying the string that i want to
print so the string of characters
and then the integer and so basically
the order that you put these format
specifiers inside of your string of text
is the order that you need to include
them using these commas so you're going
to separate each of them using a comma
so in addition to percent s and percent
d we can also use a bunch of other ones
and i'm going to talk to you guys about
some of the most common percent d will
print out an integer like 500 but if we
wanted to print out a decimal number for
example a double we could say percent f
and this is going to allow us to print
out a decimal number so i could say like
500.98754
and now this is going to print this out
onto the screen actually i need to build
this
so my favorite number is
five four 500.987540 so
essentially you can use these printfs
and you can use these format specifiers
in order to include different data types
into your output so like this is just
some general text output and we can use
these different guys to interweave like
numbers or you know other strings and
stuff like that and where these really
become useful is when we have variables
so if i was to create like a number
variable up here i could call it like
fave num
set it equal to 90.
i can use this variable and print it out
inside of this print f so over here we
could make this percent d
and instead of printing out this number
we can just access that variable so i
could say fave num and this will allow
me to print out that variable using that
printf function so my favorite number is
90. so that's the basics of using printf
this is a very awesome tool that we can
use and print app is basically just used
for us to find out information so when
we're running our programs a lot of
times we're going to want to be able to
get some information about what's going
on about what they're doing and print f
can allow us to do that so don't be
afraid to use these different access
modifiers like i said percent ask
percent d percent f those are all sort
of the common ones and you can also use
percent c and this will allow you to
print out a single character so
um i can come over here create like a
character variable
we'll call it my char and just set it
equal to like lowercase i and i could
print this out using percent c so now we
could say my char and you'll see that we
print out i so
play around with printf it's extremely
useful and it's really going to come in
handy when we're writing more complex
programs
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about working with numbers in c
now a lot of times when we're writing
programs in c we're going to want to do
different things with numbers whether
that's just storing numbers and keeping
track of them or adding multiplying
subtracting doing math with numbers or
you know really just dealing with
numbers in general so i'm just going to
give you guys a basic overview of a lot
of the stuff we can do with numbers
we're also going to talk about how
different number types interact so how
like integers and doubles interact and
all that fun stuff
so down here i am printing out a number
so you can see i'm using this printf
function and inside of these quotation
marks i'm basically saying percent f and
percent f stands for like a floating
point number so that could be either a
double or a float basically a decimal
number so when we put percent f in here
it's going to allow us to print out a
decimal number just like this and you
can see i can run my program and it'll
print out 8.9 you'll notice that it's
printing out not just 8.9 but it's also
printing it out to a very precise
decimal point and that's what c is
always going to do so it's always going
to print it out to you know a very
precise decimal so using these decimals
i can do all sorts of stuff so obviously
i can just print out the decimal but i
could also do things like math so i
could say like
5.0 plus 4.5 and
this is going to go ahead and be able to
do that for us when i run my program not
only is it going to like print this out
but it's going to do the actual math
operation you see we get 9.5 so in
addition to addition we can also use
subtraction division which is going to
be a forward slash and multiplication
which is going to be an asterisk and you
can use all these different things to
you know do the four basic math
operations addition subtraction
multiplication and division so now i
want to talk about how we can use uh
floating point numbers so like doubles
and floats
alongside integers so let's say i was
going to add an integer
with a double so if i said 5 plus 4.5
well actually when we do this this
entire answer is going to get converted
into a
decimal number so when i say 5 which is
an integer plus 4.5 we're going to get a
floating point number back so we're
going to get
9.5
and basically any operation that you do
between an integer and a floating point
number is going to return a floating
point number back
so that's important to realize but if i
was to change this to 4
now this isn't going to work anymore
because this is asking for a floating
point number and we're giving it an
integer so when i do math with two
integers it's going to give us an
integer back and if i do math with a
floating point number an integer it'll
give us a floating point number back
it's also important to realize for
example if i took 5 and divided it by 4
this should actually be a decimal number
right and you'd expect us to get a
decimal back but if i just printed out
percent d
so i printed out the result of the
integer 5 divided by the integer 4
i'm actually going to get an integer
back so when i run the program you'll
see we're getting a 1 here
but really this like the answer is 1
technically but it's one with a bunch of
decimal points after it right it's 1
plus a bunch of other stuff but when we
just do math with two integers we're
going to get an integer back if i was to
say 5 divided by 4.0 and i've printed
out a decimal now we're going to get the
entire answer back so we're gonna get
1.25
so that's just a little bit about
dealing with integers and floating point
numbers we could also take these and put
these into variables so you know in
addition to just having numbers down
here i could specify a variable like you
know
num set equal to six
and we can go ahead and print num out
down here as well i'm gonna need to make
this a d
so now we'll be able to print out that
variable with no problem so it can be
really useful sometimes to store these
numbers inside of variables i also want
to talk to you guys about using more
complex mathematical functions now in c
we have these things called functions
which are basically just little blocks
of code that we can call
and when we call them they're going to
go off and do certain things for us so
they'll like modify a value or give us
information about a value and these
functions can be really useful i'm going
to show you guys a couple functions that
we can use with math
so i'm just going to come over here and
i can actually start using these
functions and all you have to do is just
type out the name of the function that
you want to use so by default c is going
to give us access to a bunch of math
functions that we can use so we really
don't have to do anything all we have to
do is just type in their names and i'm
going to show you guys one it's just
p-o-w so i'm just typing in p-o-w then
i'm going to type in open and closed
parentheses and inside of this
parentheses i can actually give this two
numbers what this is going to do is it's
going to take the first number that we
give it and it's going to take it to the
second number so if i said like 2 and 3
and you'll notice i'm separating them
with a comma this is basically going to
give us 2 raised to the third power so
it'll give us 2 cubes so when i run my
program and actually we need to print
this out as a decimal number so this is
going to give us a decimal number back
so i need to print this out with f
when i run my program we're going to get
8 back just like that so it's basically
it's cubing two i could say like four
raised to the third power and now we
should get back 64 which we do
so that can be pretty useful there's a
couple other ones i'll show you another
one is sqrt so this will allow you to
take a numbers square root so if i said
like 36 in here
now we're going to print out uh the
square root of 36 which is going to be
six and there's a couple other ones so
let's say that i had a decimal i could
say
ceil which stands for ceiling
so if i had like
36.7 or 36.356
this is going to give us the hot the
next highest number so it'll basically
round this number up
and this is going to give us
37 as you can see
we can do another one which is called
floor
and floor will do the opposite so floor
will just round the number down no
matter what so if i had like 36.656
this will round it down to 36.
so there's all sorts of little you know
things we can do
little functions that we can call and
get information about numbers and like i
said these functions will either like
modify a number so it would like give us
the floor or the ceiling or sometimes
they'll like give us information about
numbers so that's sort of the basics of
working with numbers you know you can do
all sorts of math with numbers you can
add and subtract multiply and you can
even multiply and subtract uh integer
numbers and floating point numbers so
play around with all these uh different
things with numbers and if you want to
find some more of these little math
functions all you have to do is just go
online and google search for c math
functions there's like dozens of these
little functions that you can use but i
think these are some of the most
widely used
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about using comments and c
well comment is a special block of code
in c
which actually gets ignored when we run
our program so if you want to write a
comment you can use a special starting
and ending tag and any of the text any
of the code anything that you put inside
of that tag
isn't going to get executed or really
looked at by c so we can use comments to
do all sorts of things you know you can
leave little notes or little comments
inside of your program you can use
comments to temporarily disable certain
lines of code they can be really useful
so i'm going to show you guys the basics
down here in my program if i want to
create a comment i can start a comment
using a forward slash and an asterisk
and you'll see when i put this asterisk
in all the code in my text editor
changed color and basically what this
means is anything that comes after this
forward slash and asterix is going to be
considered a comment in order to close
off the comment i can use an another
asterisk and another forward slash
you'll see the code changed back to
normal code inside of these two
asterisks i can basically write out
anything i want and it's going to get
considered as a comment so
for example if i you know wrote out like
my program and i ran my program this
whole thing is going to get ignored by c
so it's just going to print out comments
or fun it's not going to do anything
else
and you know like i said comments are
really useful so i could leave a little
note up here i could
write something like to do like i have
to do something um and a lot of times
people will use comments to explain
certain lines of code so i could put a
comment here and i could say like this
prints out text right so maybe you know
this was like a really complex line of
code we could use this text in order to
explain it you can also use comments to
do something called commenting out a
line of code so for example let's say i
wanted to run my program but i didn't
want to have this line of code in there
well one thing i could do would just be
to delete the entire line of code right
so i could delete this code and now i
can run my program and it's no longer
going to print it out it's no longer
going to do anything but here's the
problem in order to do that i had to
actually delete the line of code so
instead of deleting it i could just
bring it back and i could comment it out
so i could basically surround it with
these comment tags
and now the computer is just going to
ignore it so it's not going to render it
because it's been commented out
so now when i run my program it's going
to do the same thing it won't execute
that line of code
but i didn't have to actually delete the
line i could just comment it out so a
lot of times when you're writing
programs you might want to try to run
your program without a certain line or a
certain you know series of lines of code
and instead of deleting them and then
running the program you can just comment
them out and c will basically ignore
them so that can be really useful so
those are the two basic uses for
comments and essentially comments are
open right it's just a way that we can
write out information in our files that
won't get rendered by c and so you can
really use comments to do whatever you
want now i will say one best practice
with comments is to use them sparingly
generally you only want to use a comment
when you absolutely have to so it can be
really annoying if you open up a c file
and there's like comments littered all
around and obviously if you want to put
a bunch of comments in your code i mean
no one's stopping you but as a best
practice going forward i think generally
only using comments when they're
absolutely necessary is kind of like a
good practice but again it's open you
know you can use comments for whatever
you want
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about constants in c
well constant is a special type of
variable in c which can't be modified so
when i create a constant and see i'm
basically creating a value that is
unable to be modified
so i'm going to show you guys basically
how this works so let's say i created a
variable let's say i created an integer
i just called it num and i set it equal
to 5 right and then i printed out that
integer onto the screen so we can print
this out percent d
and i'm just going to print out num
right so i can create this num variable
i can print it out onto the screen let's
say that down here i wanted to modify
num so i could basically say num is
equal to 8 so i can modify the value
that's stored inside of the num variable
and let's come down here and we'll print
this out as well so
percent d
and we'll print out num again and
actually i'm going to print out a new
line here
so when i go ahead and run this program
and i forgot a semicolon
when i go ahead and run this program
you'll see we're printing out five and
then we modify the value to eight and
then we printed out 8. so i was able to
modify this value down here i was able
to modify num but in certain
circumstances in c you're going to want
to create variables or you're going to
want to create values that can't be
modified so these would be values that
just like can't change and those are
called constants so if i wanted to make
num a constant in other words let's say
for some reason i didn't want the num
variable to be able to be modified in my
program i could come over here and i
could say const so c-o-n-s-t
and i'm going to say that right before i
declare the type now you can also say
const
right after you declare the type
but i've always preferred to just put it
before
so i say const int num5 and now this
program is actually going to throw an
error so when i try to run this
you'll see down here it's getting
highlighted in red that's because i
can't modify a constant so i'm trying to
modify num down here but i can't because
i gave it this const keyword because
it's now considered a constant so in a
lot of cases you'll want to have
variables that just can't be modified
can't be changed and in a situation like
that you want to make them consonants
also a lot of times when we make
constant variables in c we'll give them
uh all uppercase names and this isn't
required this is just sort of like what
a lot of developers will do so they'll
say like instead of num like this they
would say like num or maybe this is like
your favorite number so you could say
fave underscore num so that would be how
you could like distinguish two words but
generally like constants will be all
capital and that's just so it's kind of
obvious that they're unchangeable that
they're constants but again you don't
have to do that but that's kind of like
a best practice so this is one way that
we can create a constant and we
basically create a constant variable
that can't be changed but a constant
could also refer to just like any number
or any text that we're using in our
program so for example i'm gonna get rid
of this if i came down here and i just
like printed out some text so let's say
i just printed out like hello
this is actually also going to be
considered a constant so this is just
like a string of characters a string of
text that's also considered a constant
because it's just like text on the
screen we can't change it we can't
modify it it's just kind of there so you
would also consider this a constant if i
was printing out a number two like let's
say i came over here and printed out 70
70 is also considered a constant so it's
just considered to be like a piece of
information or a piece of data in our
program that is sort of unchanging right
so 70 this isn't going to change i mean
unless i physically came in here and
changed it like this value is always
going to be 90 no matter what i can't
modify it unless i like manually come in
and modify it so that's also considered
a constant
but i would say like for the most part
like where this is going to come in
handy is obviously doing stuff like this
but creating constant variables
variables that can't change
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to get input from a user in c
so a lot of times in our c programs
we're going to be working with all
different types of information and a lot
of times we're going to want to get some
of that information from the user so i'm
going to show you guys how we can prompt
the user to enter in some information we
can take that information store it
inside of variables and then we can use
it inside of our program so this is
going to be pretty cool so down here i
will basically write out the code for
this and the first thing we want to do
whenever we're getting input from the
user
is we want to prompt them so i want to
prompt the user you know as far as what
they should enter in so i'm just going
to say printf
and over here i'm just gonna print out a
prompt so
why don't we um
ask the user to enter in their age so
we'll i'll show you guys how we can get
a number from the user so i'm just gonna
say enter
your age
and now that we've prompted them to
enter their age i need to do two things
so the first thing i want to do is
create a variable where we can store
the input that the user puts into the
program so i want to create a variable
where we can store
the age that the user inputs so i'm
going to create an n over here it's
called age
and i'm not going to give this a value
so all i'm going to do up here is just
declare the variable i'm just going to
tell c
that i want to use this variable but i'm
not going to give it a value in other
words i'm going to allow the user who's
inputting the age to give this a value
so down here i want to be able to get
input for from the user so i can use
another function which is called scanf
and scanf is basically going to allow
the user to enter in some information
into our program
and this works similar to print f it's
kind of doing the opposite of printf
right printf is printing something out
onto the screen scanf is allowing the
user to input something
into the program
and we're going to make an open and
close quotation marks and in here i
basically want to tell c
what type of information i'm asking the
user to enter in so in our case we're
asking for an integer right age is going
to be an integer it's a whole number
so i'm going to accept as an input and
integer
and over here we want to tell c where we
want to put that integer so i'm
basically going to tell c
what variable i want to store this in so
i'm going to store this inside of my age
variable
and i can essentially just type out the
name of the variable here
but in order to get input from the user
i'm actually going to have to type an
ampersand in front of this so instead of
just typing out age i'm going to have to
type ampersand
age and when i say ampersand age this is
what's called a pointer and we're going
to talk about pointers in a later
tutorial i'm going to cover everything
you need to know about pointers but for
now that's a little bit beyond what we
need to learn so all you need to know is
that when you're using scanf and you
want to store information inside of like
an integer or a float or like a
character you need to use this ampersand
over here
so down here now that we've scanned for
the user's age i'm just going to go
ahead and print it out so we'll just
print out like u r
and i'll say percent d
years old and over here i'm just going
to print out that age variable so
essentially what i'm doing is i'm
prompting the user to enter their age
i'm storing whatever age they enter
inside of this age variable and then i'm
printing it out to them
so let's go ahead and run this program
and we'll see how we did so i'm going to
run the program and it says enter your
age so let's say someone is 50. when i
click enter it's going to take that
value it's going to take that integer
that we entered 50.
store it inside of that age variable and
print it out you'll see over here it
says you are 50 years old so that's how
we can get an integer from the user we
can also get like a double from the user
so
for example i could say enter your gpa
and so now instead of
asking for an integer we're going to be
asking for a double so i could come up
here and say like double
and we could call this gpa and now i can
do the same thing but instead of saying
d i want to say lf and lf is basically
going to tell the scanf function that
we're looking for a double and then
obviously instead of age we're just
going to put gpa inside of here and so
now we can just say like
your gpa is
and then
we can put percent f because we're going
to be printing out a double
and i'll just say gpa so you'll notice
here in printf when we want to use a
double we're using percent f to print it
out
but when we're using scanf we're going
to use percent lf so that's just like a
little difference and now let's go ahead
and run this program and we should be
able to get a gpa so let's say someone's
gpa is like 3.1
now it says your gpa is 3.1 so that's
how we can get a double i also want to
show you guys how we can get a character
so why don't we create a character up
here and we'll just call it grade
and we'll say enter your grade
and now when we want to get a character
we can just say percent c
and again i can just come down here and
say ampersand grade
and then down here we can just say your
grade
is
percent c
and we'll go ahead and print out the
grade so now we should be able to get a
character from the user
so enter the grade let's say i got an a
and it says your grade is a so we can
use this scan f to get specific types of
input from the user and we can store
those specific types of input inside of
variables now i also want to show you
guys one more thing we can do which is
we can actually get a string from the
user so in addition to getting numbers
and a character we could also get like a
string of characters from the user
and this is going to be a little bit
different from uh doing like numbers and
characters so i want to kind of show you
guys how we can do this really quick so
over here let's create a variable we'll
just call it let's just call it name so
we'll be storing someone's name
and
whenever we're creating a string of
characters we always need these open and
close square brackets and inside of here
i'm actually going to specify how many
characters i want to be able to store
inside this string of characters so i'm
just going to put 20
and in the past in this course when we
when we've been creating strings we
haven't put a number in there we've just
kind of said like whatever right we've
basically just given this a value
straight away but in this particular
situation we're not going to be giving
this variable of value right away in
other words like i don't know what the
user's name is going to be like i don't
know that right up front they're going
to tell us what that is
and so if i'm not going to give this a
value right away i do actually need to
tell c
how big i want this variable to be in
other words i need to tell c how many
characters i want this variable to be
able to store and that way c can go
ahead and allocate enough memory for
this variable so i'm just going to put
20 and 20 basically means this will be
able to store 20 characters
and i think that's enough for a name so
down here we'll just say enter your name
and i can use scanf in order to get
input in the form of a string but
instead of saying percent c i'm just
going to say percent s and over here
instead of saying ampersand grade i'm
just going to type out the name of the
string of characters so i don't actually
need this ampersand here i can just
specify the name of the string so down
here it says printf your grade is
and actually let's just say your name
is
i would just say percent s and then over
here we can print out the name
so this should work just like it did in
the other cases so let's go ahead and
run this and it says enter your name so
my name is mike
and you'll see it says your name is mike
so that works out really well
but there is one problem when we're
using scanf in order to get
a string from the user so for example if
i came in here and i said enter your
name and i said my name was john smith
when i click enter
you'll notice that it's only saying your
name is john it's not including smith
over here
and here's the problem this is because
whenever i use this scanf function and i
use it with a string it's only going to
grab the characters up to the first
space so once it sees a space it's going
to be like okay we're done getting
characters right so that's kind of a
problem and that's just kind of how
scanf works it's not really you know
scanf's fault
there is a way that we can modify scanf
in order to be able to get input with
spaces
but there's another function which i
want to show you guys which we can use
to get a line of text from the user and
it's called f gets
and fgets is another function it's
similar to scanf but f gets is basically
going to be more general so afghats is
essentially just going to grab like a
whole line of text it's not going to be
able to grab it and store it inside of
like an integer or a vari or or a
character it's just going to be able to
store it inside of like a string of
characters
so when we're using fgets the first
argument we want to give it is the name
of the variable where we want to store
the line of text so in our case it's
just going to be this name variable
the next thing we want to do is specify
how many characters we want to be able
to input from the user so this will
essentially limit the amount of
characters that the user can input
and this is always a good idea when
we're trying to get a string from the
user because one common problem is that
the user could try to enter in like a
million characters and they would
overflow the like the buffer in other
words like c wouldn't be able to handle
accepting that many characters and the
program might break
so over here with fgats we can specify
how many characters we want to be able
to accept so i'm just going to say 20
because that's how many characters we
can store inside of this variable and
over here i'm just going to say stdin
and this stands for standard input
essentially what we're doing over here
is we're telling f gets
where we want to get the information
from and standard input is set is
essentially just like that little
console that we've been using
so now i'm using fgets and this is going
to do exactly what scanf did so we'll be
able to store
the input inside of this name variable
but now we'll be able to
store
multiple words instead of just one
single word so let's run this program
and it says enter your name so now if we
entered in john smith
you'll see it's able to enter in john
smith
now the one downside with uh just using
this f gets is you'll notice that it
printed out this new line over here so
let me actually demonstrate this a
little bit
so if i was to print out like you know
just some random text over here
whenever i get input using scan f so if
i entered in john smith
when i click the enter key so when i'm
entering this by clicking the enter key
that's actually going to represent a new
line character and that's going to get
stored
inside of the string so when i click
enter you'll notice it says your name is
john smith then it prints out a new line
character and it prints out this text so
that's just something that you need to
be aware of when you're using this f
gets function
but for the most part i would say if
you're getting input from a user in the
form of a string you can use f gets you
could also use scan f and you could use
multiple
percent s's and i'm actually going to
show you guys how we could do something
like that in a future tutorial but for
the most part i would say whenever
you're getting a string from the user
you just want to use f gets so that's
the basics of getting input from the
user like i said there's a couple other
things that we can do and i'm going to
talk about
at least one other way that we can get
strings from the user
in a future tutorial but this is kind of
the basics and you can kind of play
around with doing this stuff in your
programs
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how to build a basic calculator in
c we're basically going to build a
little program where the user can enter
in two numbers and then our program will
take those two numbers add them together
and spit out the answer so this is going
to be kind of cool and we'll also learn
about getting numbers as input from a
user
so over here i want to show you guys
exactly how we can do this the first
thing i want to do is print out a prompt
so i basically want to prompt the user
for some input so over here i can just
say printf
and inside of here we're just going to
give them a little prompt so i'll say
enter first number
and
essentially what we're going to have
them do is enter in two numbers so i'm
actually going to create two variables
up here so we'll make an int and we'll
call it num1
and then we'll make another int and
we'll call it num2
and i'm not actually going to give these
values right up front we're going to end
up giving these whatever the user enters
in so after the user enters the first
number we need to actually grab that
number so i can use another c function
called scanf
and in here we're basically just going
to say percent d because we want to grab
an integer and then over here i'm going
to say the name of the variable where i
want to store the value that gets
entered now if you're following along
with this course in the last tutorial we
were able to get a string of characters
as input from the user and basically we
just typed in like the name of the
variable but when we're getting input
that's not a string of characters in
other words when we're getting input
that's not percent s so if it's like
percent d or percent f or percent c so
if it's like a a decimal or an integer
or a float or a character we actually
need to use a special symbol this
ampersand so i'm going to have to say
ampersand and then the name of the
variable where i want to store this
value so i'm just going to say ampersand
one and basically what this means is
we're accessing the address of num1 and
we're going to talk about addresses and
pointers in a future video but for now
just know that you need
this ampersand here in order to store
the value that gets entered inside of
this variable so once we do that now we
can move on and we're basically just
going to do the same exact thing but for
the second number so i'm gonna copy
these
and i'll paste this and now instead of
saying enter first number we'll say
enter
second number
and we're just gonna store this inside
of num two
all right so once we're done with this
the last thing we want to do is add them
together and print out the answer so i'm
just going to come down here i'm going
to say printf
and we'll just say answer and over here
we'll print out the answer so it's going
to be an integer and we're basically
just going to print out num1 plus num2
so we're going to print out the value of
num1 plus num2. so we have our basic
calculator we're getting the first
number we're getting the second number
we're storing them inside of these
variables we're adding them together and
printing them out
let's try to run our calculator so i'm
going to run my program and you'll see
over here it says enter first number so
let's go ahead and enter a six enter
second number we'll enter a
eight and now we're going to get 14. so
14 is the correct answer so our program
worked it was able to add the numbers
correctly and everything's awesome
but let me show you guys one problem
with this program if i wanted to do math
on multiple on decimal numbers for
example if i said 2 and then over here i
said like 6.8 when i add these together
we're not going to get the correct
answer we're going to get 6 plus 2
which is going to be an integer 8 but
we're not going to get 8.8 so we're not
getting the correct value so instead of
letting the user enter in only integers
why don't we instead let them enter in
doubles so over here i'm going to change
these to double so i'm going to say num1
is going to be a double num2 is going to
be a double and since we're getting
doubles as input we're going to have to
come down here and modify these so right
now this is accepting an integer
but we want to make this accept a double
so normally if we're using printf and we
wanted to print out a double we would
say f and that stands for like floating
point number but when we're scanning for
a number if we want to use a double we
have to say lf just like that so down
here i'm also going to say lf
and we'll change this to just f so
printf is a little bit different than
scanf right in scanf if we want to
accept a double as input we need to use
lf and printf
we just use percent f so
let's run our program now and we should
be able to add floating point numbers so
decimal numbers over here we'll do 4.5
plus 6.7
and we get 11.2 so that looks good to me
looks like everything is working
properly and now we have a basic
calculator so the user can enter in any
numbers that they want and the
calculator will be able to handle them
now this calculator is not like 100
iron cloud secure
for example like if i was to come up
here
and enter in like a string of characters
instead of a number you'll see that it's
gonna break the program right so it's
just like not doing what we wanted it to
do and as we go further in this course
we're gonna learn all sorts of ways that
we can check to see if certain things
are getting entered correctly and we
could basically mitigate circumstances
like that but for now this is just kind
of an introduction into how we can get
numbers as input and do things like
addition or multiplication once we have
them
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about building a little game in
a sea more specifically we're going to
be building a mad libs game now if
you've ever played the game mad libs
it's basically a game where you write
down a bunch of random words so it could
be like you know nouns or verbs or
someone's name or you know a verb ending
in ing something like that you take all
of those words that you enter in and you
kind of sprinkle them in into a story
and then generally the story is like
kind of funny because it has all these
random words in it so actually if we
head over to my web browser you'll see i
have a picture of a mad lib up here and
basically you just add in a bunch of
random words into the story and then
you'd read the story back and it could
be kind of funny so i'm going to show
you guys how we can build something like
that in c and we're also going to talk
about some more ways that we can use
that scan f function that i showed you
guys in the last tutorial so over here
we have um a little story that i printed
out it just says roses are red violets
are blue i love you kind of like a
classic poem
but i think this poem would be a lot
funnier if we turned it into a mad lib
so that's exactly what we're gonna do
i'm gonna replace roses are red i'm
going to replace red with a random color
so we're just going to have the user
enter in a color i'll replace violets
with a plural noun so we're going to
have them enter in a plural noun and i'm
going to have instead of saying i love
you we're going to say i love and then a
specific celebrity
so i'll just type in celebrity right
there
all right so
this is basically what we're going to be
printing out we're going to be printing
out roses are and then whatever color
they enter in uh plural nouns are blue
and then i love whatever celebrity so
let's talk about actually creating this
program so we're actually going to need
to do a couple things
and actually the first thing i want to
do is i want to create variables we're
going to create variables to store
the color that the user inputs the
plural noun that the user inputs and the
celebrity the user inputs we're going to
create three variables and these are
basically going to be
character strings so they're going to be
collections of characters and we can
store them in in a variable so i'm going
to create some of these variables
why don't we create one for color and
remember whenever we create a
string or like a collection of
characters we need to make these open
and closed square brackets
and what i also want to do because i'm
not going to be giving color a value
right away in other words we're letting
the user determine the value of color i
just need to tell c how many characters
we want this string to be able to store
that way c knows how much memory it
needs to allocate for this variable so
i'm just going to say 20 and we'll
basically just say they can enter in a
color that is up to 20 characters we're
gonna do the same thing for plural noun
and again we'll let them enter in 20
characters maximum
and finally we're going to do the same
thing for celebrity so again 20
characters sounds good all right now
that we have our variables created i
want to actually get information from
the user so i want to prompt the user
for information and i want to take the
information that they entered in and i
want to store it inside of each one of
these variables
first order of business is to prompt
them for input so i can just say printf
and inside here we'll basically just
type in enter a color
once we've prompted them to enter the
color we can actually get whatever color
they enter and store it inside of a
variable i'm going to use a function
called scanf
and over here i'm going to accept a
string so i'm going to accept a string
of characters
and we're going to store this inside of
our color variable just like that
and remember if you watched the last
tutorial we used the
ampersand here when we were getting
numbers or also you'd do the same thing
if you were getting a single character
but when we're getting input for a
string of characters we don't need that
ampersand so you can just get rid of
that let's copy these and i'm going to
paste this two more times so the second
thing we want to get from them is going
to be the
plural noun
and i'm going to store this inside of
the plural noun variable so you can see
now we're getting the plural noun
and finally we're going to do the same
thing for celebrity and again we're
going to get that celebrity
okay cool
so now i'm getting the color i'm getting
the plural noun and i'm getting the
celebrity so the last thing we have to
do is we have to take all of these
variables and put them into our story
right so we need to be able to print out
the story with all of those variables so
i'm going to come down here
and i'm just going to say percent s and
over here we'll pass in the color
same thing here i'm going to replace the
plural noun here with a
percent s and we'll pass in the
plural noun and finally same thing for
celebrity down here
all right so everything seems to be
wired up and you'll notice that i have
new lines here so that this story prints
out on new lines
let's go ahead and run this program and
we'll see how we did
so over here it's prompting us for a
color why don't we enter in magenta
enter a plural noun let's do
microwaves
and enter a celebrity why don't we just
say
prince so when i click enter it's going
to say roses are magenta microwaves are
blue i love prints so we were able to
prompt the user to enter in all of that
input we took everything that they input
we stored it in variables and we printed
all those variables out inside of our
story and we have our mad lib the
program seems to be working really well
i do want to show you guys one way that
this program could mess up so let's go
ahead and run this again
so let's enter in a different color i'm
going to enter in like blue
enter in a plural noun so why don't we
enter in
phones
and now enter in a celebrity so i'm
going to show you guys one way that we
could actually break this program
if i entered in a celebrity with a first
and a last name like tom hanks when i
click enter now
you'll notice that instead of saying i
love tom hanks it's only saying i love
tom
here's the problem when we use that scan
f function scanf is only going to grab
characters up to the first white space
so essentially when we put this space
here we're telling c that we don't want
to grab anymore
but in reality we want to be able to
grab the actor's full name we want to be
able to grab the celebrities first and
last name if need be
so this is a situation in c where we
would have to modify our little program
so what i could do is instead of just
getting one variable like the celebrity
i could actually get two so i could say
over here like celebrity f and that'll
stand for celebrity first name
and then down here we can make another
variable called celebrity l that'll
stand for last name so now when we scan
instead of just scanning for one string
of characters i can scan for two strings
of characters and we'll have celebrity f
and then celebrity l
and down here we're going to want to do
the same thing so we can just say
celebrity f and
celebrity l
and we just need to add another percent
here so it's going to say i love
celebrities first name and celebrity's
last name so let's run our program and
see how we did so i could enter in like
red and
microphones and now we can enter in tom
hanks
and we're printing out the actors first
and last name so that's one way that we
can remedy this program and make it be
able to accept two inputs with a space
in the middle and that also just shows
you guys a little bit more about how
scan f works so it's going to stop
scanning it's going to stop getting the
input at that first space now here's the
thing about this program though if i
wanted to enter in a celebrity
with uh who only had one name so if i
only wanted to enter in one the program
actually isn't going to be able to
handle that so if i said like hats and
down here if i said
like gandhi
and i click enter you'll notice that
it's still waiting for me to enter in a
last name right so i can enter in
something here and then the program will
work
but it was waiting for me after i
entered in just that one name so that's
something that you're gonna have to you
know play around with in your programs
basically c is gonna force you to be
very specific about what the user is
entering so if the user needs to enter
two things like two words then you need
to specify that if the user is only
going to enter in one word you have to
specify that so you have to be very
specific when you're getting input from
the user like that
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about using arrays in c
a lot of times when we're writing our c
programs we're going to be dealing with
a bunch of different data and one of the
things we can do to control and manage
and sort of keep track of and organize
that data is put data inside of things
called arrays an array is really useful
because it's basically a container where
we can store a piece of information
but what happens in your programs when
you're dealing with huge amounts of
information specifically huge amounts of
information that are related right
imagine i had a list of like a bunch of
names or a list of a bunch of numbers
that i needed to keep track of
let's say i had like a list of 100
numbers right i wouldn't want to have to
create a hundred different variables to
store all of those different numbers and
this is where arrays come in an array is
essentially a data structure where we
can store a bunch of different data
values so inside of an array unlike a
variable where i can only store one
value i can store hundreds or thousands
or even millions of values so inside of
a single array i could store like five
things or seven things or ten numbers or
twenty characters you know i could sort
a bunch of different pieces of
information and then all that
information would be nice and neat and
organized in my program so i'm going to
show you guys how to create arrays we
can create an array a lot like we create
a normal variable and a variable in
array are very similar right a variable
is basically used to define a container
that stores a single value and an array
is used to define a container that
stores you know any number of values so
the first thing we're going to have to
do when we create an array is give c
some information and the first piece of
information is what type of data we want
to store inside of the array so for
example i could say int and now i'd be
creating an array that would hold
integers if i said char i'd be creating
an array that would hold characters
or if i said like double same thing but
for double numbers so why don't we
create an array of integers and i'm just
going to call this lucky
numbers whenever i create an array i
always want to use a special little
symbol and this symbol will tell c
that instead of just creating a normal
variable we want to create an array and
it's an open and closed square brackets
whenever i use these open and close
square brackets after the name it's
going to tell c like okay we want to
store multiple pieces of information
now there's a bunch of different ways we
can create these arrays the easiest one
though is to just say equals and i can
make an open enclosed curly bracket and
inside of this open and close curly
bracket i can just start typing out some
numbers that i want to put in this array
so we could type out like 4
8 15
16 23
42 now i could basically type out as
many numbers as i wanted and i could
store them inside of this array so over
here i you know i printed out six
numbers i could print out 600 if i
wanted you know the only thing that's
limiting me is how many i can actually
put in here so you'll notice that i put
in the piece of data so like four for
example and then i put a comma and a
comma is gonna separate all the elements
in the array so we would say four is the
first element in the array eight is the
second element in the array these are
all considered to be elements
inside of this array and what's cool
about this array is it's now storing all
of this information so unlike a variable
where we can only store one value now in
this array i'm storing six different
numbers so if i wanted i can print this
out and i'm actually going to print this
out just to show you guys so remember
we're going to print out a
number and i'm going to show you guys
how we can access specific elements
inside of this array
so all of these numbers are stored in
this lucky numbers array in this array
structure but the question becomes how
do we access them right how can i gain
access to one of these well i could say
percent d so i'm going to print this out
and now i can just say
lucky numbers so i'm going to refer to
the name of the array and when i want to
access a specific element i can make an
open and close square bracket and inside
of this open and close square bracket i
want to put the index of the element
that i want to access so all of these
elements in here have a specific index
and i can access them by putting the
index inside of this square bracket so
if i wanted to access this 4 for example
i can put a 0 inside of here and now
when i run my program you guys will see
that we'll be able to print out that 4.
so over here i'm printing out four
if i wanted to access this 15 i can put
a
two in here so now when i run my program
i'll be accessing the 15 as you can see
so one thing you might have noticed by
now is that we start the indexes and
arrays at zero so when i wanted to
access this 4 instead of putting a 1 in
here i put a 0 in here right you might
think that 4 would be at index position
1 because it's the first element in the
array but in c we start array indexes at
0. so actually the first element this 4
is going to be at index position 0. so
if i was going to write out indexes i
would say like 4 is it index position 0.
this 8 is at index position 1. this 15
is at index position 2 16 is at index
position 3 etc so that's going to allow
me to access all these elements inside
of the ray individually so i could print
them out just by referring to the index
inside of these square brackets another
thing i can do is i can modify some of
the elements inside of here so let's say
i want to modify lucky numbers in x
position 1. so let's say i want to
modify this eight so i don't like this
eight anymore so i could basically just
assign this a different value like i
normally would so i could say
lucky numbers
and i can make an open and close square
bracket we can say one
and i can just set it equal to something
else so i could set this equal to like
200. and now when we print out lucky
numbers one instead of printing out an
eight it's going to be printing out a
200. so let's go ahead and do that and
run my program and you'll see we're
printing out 200 instead of eight so you
can modify any of the individual
elements inside the array just by
referring to the index and really when
you think about this conceptually
an array is basically just holding a
bunch of variables but those variables
don't have names so when i access lucky
numbers one it's the same as me
accessing an integer variable it's just
that you know the array is holding
potentially hundreds or thousands or
millions of these different variables so
an array is a very useful structure
especially if you're storing data that
is very similar
so like i said i could do this with an n
i could also do this with a double i
could do this with a float i could do
this with whatever i wanted but there's
going to be situations where you might
not necessarily know all the elements
that you want to put inside your array
so let's say i'm creating an array and i
don't know
what numbers i want to put in it yet so
maybe i just like want to create it i
want to tell c that we need it but i
don't want to necessarily put anything
in it right away
well up here we're basically saying
lucky numbers the open and close square
brackets and then we're giving it a
bunch of information but if we don't
want to give it all that information
instead i can just put a co a semicolon
here
but inside of these square brackets i
need to tell c
how many elements that this array can
hold so i need to tell c like hey this
array can only hold like 10 elements or
this array can hold 20 elements or
whatever so let's say we wanted an array
that could hold like 10 elements
i can put a 10 right here and now the
capacity of this integer array is 10. so
it has the potential to hold 10 items
and what i could do is i could come down
here and i could start assigning values
to those items so i could say like
lucky numbers
1 is equal to 80 right so i'm giving
lucky numbers 1 a value and now over
here i could print that value out onto
the screen and you'll see we're printing
out 80. but if i try to print out for
example lucky numbers 0 so the lucky
numbers in exposition 0
this is going to give me a negative 2
which basically means that it's not
found so
basically means that there's no
element inside of lucky numbers at index
position 0. but if i wanted i could
do that so i could say like lucky
numbers
0 is equal to 90.
and now when i run my program it's going
to be able to
do that so it'll be able to get that
value so in a lot of situations you're
just going to want to give these arrays
values up front right off the bat but in
a lot of other situations you're not
going to necessarily know what's
supposed to go in there
but in a situation like that you still
have to tell c
how many elements the array is going to
hold you still have to like rigorously
define like hey this array can only hold
10 elements and that's just so c is able
to allocate enough memory in order to
hold all of those elements so that's
kind of the basics of working with
arrays now i do want to point out one
thing that we've been using in this
course
has been uh strings so i've been
creating character strings so i could
say like char phrase and i could set
this equal to
draft academy or other times in the
program we created like when we were
making our little game we created an
arrays and i would just say like 20 and
then i would get input from the user
and put that information in here this is
basically a string of characters so
anytime we create a string in c like if
i was to create a string over here i
called it like a ray or whatever this is
an array
so we've kind of just been taking this
for granted like i've kind of just been
calling this a string or calling it like
a string of characters but it's
basically just an array of characters
the only difference is this is such a
common thing to use in our programs that
c makes it a little c makes it special
and makes it really easy for us to
create it but just like that array of
integers this is also an array so now
you kind of have a better understanding
of what strings are and what they're
actually doing
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about functions in c
a function is basically just a
collection of code that performs a
specific task
so what you can do is you can take a
bunch of code you know maybe like five
or six or 20 lines of code and put it
inside of a function and then when you
want to access that code that's inside
the function you can call the function
and generally when you create a function
you'll design the function to perform a
specific task so the function will have
a specific purpose so i'm going to show
you guys how to create functions how to
work with them and we'll just talk about
the basics of using functions like i
said a function is basically just a
collection of code that does a specific
task so we can actually create a
function here in our c program now
you'll notice up here we have this block
of code it says int main and there's an
open and closed parentheses and an open
and closed curly brackets and we've kind
of just been using this for
the entire course like up to this point
in the course we've just been kind of
using this main little block of code
here but actually this is a function
and sometimes you'll hear people call
this a method as well so function and
method are two words that essentially
mean the same thing
but generally in c we're going to refer
to these as functions but this is called
the main function and the main function
is basically a function that's going to
get executed when we start running our
program and so we've already been using
a function this main function but if you
want we could actually create other
functions in our program so i'm going to
show you guys how to do that so let's go
down and we're going to go here outside
of this function and the way you can
tell we're outside the function is we're
outside of this ending curly bracket so
down here
i'm going to create a function and when
we create a function we actually have to
give
c a couple pieces of information the
first thing we have to tell c is the
return type of the function so actually
we're going to talk more about return
type in the next tutorial but for now
just know that return type is basically
the type of data that the function is
going to return to the user so sometimes
your function can actually give
information back to whoever calls it in
our case though we're just going to say
void and void basically means that this
function isn't going to return any
information that's the first thing that
you have to tell c the second thing we
have to do is give this function a name
and generally when we're naming a
function we're going to want to name the
function according to what it does
so in our case we're going to create a
function that says hi to the user so i'm
just going to call this function say hi
because that's what it's going to do
it's going to say hi
whenever i create a function now i want
to make an open and closed parentheses
and i'm going to make an open and closed
curly bracket
so now
any code that goes in between these
curly brackets is going to be considered
code that's inside of this function
so let me show you guys i'm just going
to make this a very simple function
we're going to do one thing inside of
here we're just going to make a printf
and we're going to print out hello user
so i've created my function it's called
say hi and inside of this function we're
just printing out hello user so now
let's go ahead and run our program and
see what happens so i'm just going to
build and run my program
but you'll see up here that hello user
doesn't get printed out right in other
words i came down here i said printf
hello user but this didn't get printed
out and this is the first lesson with
functions is that in order to use the
code inside of the function we have to
call it
calling a function basically means we're
telling c that we want to execute all
the code inside of it so if i want to
execute this code i can call this
function and the way that i do that is
just by typing out the name of the
function and then open and close
parentheses
so now instead of just printing out
nothing c is actually going to go over
here and execute all the code in the say
hi function so let's run our code
and you'll see now we're printing out
hello user
so the difference between this main
function up here and this say hi
function is this main function is a very
special function right when we run our
program this main function basically
gets called then if we want to use other
functions we can call them from inside
of this main function and that's sort of
how this is going to work so also i want
to show you guys one other thing
i just want to illustrate um
the flow that these functions take i
want to show you guys how these get
executed by the program so i'm printing
out top and i'm printing out bottom and
i'm calling say hi right here so now i'm
going to run my program again
and you'll see we're printing out top
then we're printing out hello user then
we're printing out bottom and this might
have looked a little bit better if i put
new lines but essentially what's
happening is when c goes to execute this
program it's going to execute this first
line of code printf so it's going to
print out top
then we're telling c that we want to
call
the say hi function c is now going to
jump over here to the say hi function
and it's gonna execute all of the code
inside of here so in this case we just
have one line of code but i could put
any number of lines of code inside this
function so if i had like five lines of
code it would execute all five of those
lines of code then it's going to jump
back up here and it's going to move on
to the next instruction so that's kind
of how that works and that's sort of the
basics of writing functions anytime you
have a block of code or a bunch of code
that does one thing or that you want to
kind of encapsulate into its own little
container that you can call you can put
it inside of a function and then
whenever you want to access it you just
call it but these functions can actually
do a lot more so one thing we can do is
we can give these functions some
information so i can actually give this
function a piece of information and it
can use that information to do different
things this is what's called a parameter
and a parameter is basically just a
value that we give to a function so
let's say in this say high function
instead of just saying hi to the user we
wanted to say hi to someone specifically
well i can actually come down here in
these parentheses and i can specify a
function parameter and i can specify a
parameter a lot like i would specify a
variable so i could say for example char
name and then open and close square
brackets and i'm basically what i'm
saying down here is this say high
function is going to take as a parameter
in other words as an input
a string of characters called name
and what i can do is i can come down
here and i can actually print that out
so i could say percent s and we could
print out name
now over here when i call this say hi
function because i specified that it's
going to take a parameter i have to give
it a string so i could give this a
string like
mic like i'll put my name in here
when i call this say hi function now i'm
passing the value mic into this function
so mike is going to get stored inside of
this name array and we're going to be
able to print it out down here let's go
ahead and run our program and you'll see
it says hello mic
so instead of saying hello user now
we're able to customize what it says the
cool thing about this is i could copy
this line of code like i could call this
function a bunch of times with different
names actually i'm going to put a new
line down here so this is more obvious
if i could say hello mike hello tom
hello
oscar
now when i run my program
it's saying hello to each of these
different people and because we define
the function and we can pass it
different names and depending on what we
pass it depending on the parameter that
we give it it'll perform its task a
little bit differently
you can also specify multiple parameters
so let's say in addition to accepting
the name as a parameter we also accepted
their age so i could say char name
and then down here i can specify int age
and now we're basically saying that this
is going to take an age as well so i
could say hello
and then i could say you are and we'll
say the age
so now over here instead of in addition
to just saying name we can also say age
so now when i run this function and when
i call it i have to also give this an
age so we can say like 40
23
and 70.
and now this is gonna print out all that
information for us so hello mike you are
40 hello tom you're 23. hello oscar
you're 70. and you can pass as many
parameters as you want into one of these
functions you always just have to make
sure though that you're passing a
parameter when you're calling the
function just like that so that's the
basics of using functions and in the
next tutorial we're going to talk about
this guy over here which is the return
type and we're going to look at how we
can get information back from a function
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about return statements in c
a return statement is a special line of
code that we can include in our
functions which will allow them to
return information back to whoever
called them so i can write a function
and i can have that function give
information back
to whoever called it that could be
information like the result of some
operation or you know it could be a
message telling whoever called it how
the function went it could be anything
like that so i'm going to show you guys
basically how we can do that and i'll
just give you an overview of like return
types and all that stuff so down here
i'm actually going to create a function
and we're going to create a function
that cubes a number so when you cube a
number generally you take it to the
third power so i could say like 2 raised
to the third power
which is the same as just saying 2 times
2 times 2 this would be cubing a number
right you're taking it to the third
power
so i'm going to make a function that's
going to do that basically this function
will accept one parameter which is going
to be a number and it'll cube that
number and then once it's done cubing
the number it'll give that value back to
the caller and you guys will see how
that will work so
i do want to point out one thing
whenever we are returning values in our
function so if you're going to write a
function that's going to return a value
you always want to put it above the
function that's going to be calling it
so for example like this main function
down here this is the first function
that executes so any code we put in here
is going to get executed first if i want
to return a value with my function i'm
going to define the function here above
the main method and there's a couple
reasons why we want to do that
essentially it'll just make sure that
everything works correctly so we want to
make sure that we define this function
before we actually call it down here and
get a value back so the first thing that
i need to tell c when i want to create a
function is what type of data i want to
return
if you've been following along with this
course you'll know in the last tutorial
we used the void return type which
basically means we weren't going to
return any information but now we want
to actually return information right so
we want to cube a number so why don't we
return a double and you can put any data
type here you want you could also put
like int or a character or a character
array but let's just do double and we're
going to give this a name so i'm going
to call this cube
i'm going to make an open and closed
parentheses and inside of this
parentheses we're going to allow this
method or we're going to allow this
function to accept one parameter as
input so it's just going to be another
double and we'll call it num
so basically what we want to do is we
want to cube num and we want to give
that value back to the user so over here
i'm just going to create a variable
it's just going to be another double
called result and i'm going to set it
equal to num
times num times num so basically this
variable result now represents or now
stores the cubed value of num
all we need to do to return this value
now is just say
return
result
and this return keyword is basically
going to do a couple things the first
thing it does is it breaks us out of the
function so wherever we put that return
keyword it's going to break us out of
the function and it's going to return
this value
back to the caller so down here we can
actually call this function
so actually what i want to do is i want
to print out the answer that we get back
so i can do printf
and in here i'm just going to say
answer and we'll print out the answer so
percent f so i'm using percent f because
we're expecting to get a double back
from here remember double is the return
type
and over here i can just say cube
and we'll pass in a number let's pass in
3.0
essentially what's going to happen now
is we're going to call this function all
this code is going to execute and this
function is going to get a value back
basically the value of cubing 3.0 so
normally like in the past in this course
when we wanted to print out a number
we'd have to put like 4 or 76 or you
know whatever we'd have to put a number
right there
but we can just call this function
because eventually this is going to get
a number back anyway so this will
contain a number after the function's
done being called
so i can actually just run my program
now and this is going to print out the
result of cubing 3.0 so you'll see down
here we get 27.00
so
3 cubed is 27 3 times 3 is 9 9 times 3
27. so looks like our cube function
works let's try it with another number
why don't we do
7.
so let's run this again and we get 343
i'm guessing that's right
so
basically what we did is we created this
function and we use this return keyword
and we returned back to the caller the
value of cubing the number and that's
really cool and actually so we can make
this a lot simpler so i could actually
just get rid of this result variable and
i could just straight up return
num cubed and this is
and this is going to do the same exact
thing so we should get the same answer
yeah
so this can be uh really awesome and one
thing i want to point out is this return
keyword will actually break us out of
the function so if i came down here and
i said like printf
and i print it out like here
this actually this code is actually
never gonna get executed so if i was to
run my program
you'll notice that it's not printing out
here so that never gets printed out in
other words
this line of code down here printf here
this never gets touched because when we
use this return keyword
this breaks us out of the function so
whenever c sees this return keyword it
just
exits the function and goes back
down here to the normal program
so just keep in mind that you can't
really put any code after you use this
return keyword because it will break you
out of the function and i actually want
to talk to you guys about one more thing
really quick
you'll notice up here i'm creating my
cube function above the main function so
i actually created this above here and
the reason that i did that was because
if i was to move this down here below
the main function
and i try to run my program you'll
notice that we're getting an error over
here and actually if we look at the
error down here in the
output it says error conflicting types
for cube
now essentially what's happening is when
i
create this function
down here below this main method when
the main method over here tries to call
it it actually doesn't know
about this function yet like it doesn't
necessarily know like what this function
is and what it's going to return and
what parameters it's going to take
because we created it after we created
this main method so what i can do is
actually something called prototyping
and when i prototype it'll allow me to
create this function below this main
function without getting this error and
basically when you prototype i'm
basically just going to write out the
function signature so we would call this
like the signature basically
the return type and the parameters and
the name so if i was to put this up here
and put a semicolon
now when i run my program
you'll see that we're not getting this
error anymore and we're actually getting
the answer back so this is a way that
you can create functions below that main
function without having any problems and
you know basically any functions that i
created i could put another prototype up
there at the top
and uh it's gonna be fine
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about if statements in c now an
if statement is a programming structure
which we can use to help our programs to
make decisions so by using an if
statement our programs can actually
respond so in certain circumstances they
can do certain things and in other
circumstances they can do other things
and if statements are extremely powerful
and they're a great way to add some
intelligence to our programs for the
purposes of this tutorial we're going to
be building a function so we're going to
build a function and it's going to be
called the max function and basically
what this function is going to do is
it's going to take two parameters uh two
numbers and it's going to tell us which
number is the biggest so i could give it
like 4 and i could give it a 10 and
it'll tell us which number is bigger
let's go ahead and do that i'm going to
make this function up here
and it's going to return an integer and
i'm just going to call it max and it's
going to take as parameters to integers
so it's going to take an integer num1
and it's going to take another integer
num2
and now we'll just make the actual
function body so inside this function
our job is to figure out whether num1 is
the biggest or num2 is the biggest and
we're going to return the biggest to the
caller so the first thing i'm going to
do is create a variable and it's going
to be an integer and i'm just going to
call it result
and i'm not going to give it a value
right away what we need to do in this
function is we need to figure out which
one's bigger we need to figure out if
num1 is the biggest or
we need to figure out if num 2 is the
biggest and this is a perfect situation
to use an if statement an if statement
allows us to check a certain condition
and if that condition's true we can do
one thing and if the condition is false
we can do another thing so down here i'm
going to use an if statement i'm
basically just going to say if and then
we're going to make an open and close
parenthesis and i'm going to make an
open and closed curly bracket
now inside of here inside of these
parentheses we need to specify a
condition this is something that's
either going to be true or false if the
condition inside of these parentheses is
true we're going to execute the code
inside of these curly brackets if it's
false then we're just going to move on
so
in order to tell whether or not num1 is
bigger than num2 or num2 is bigger than
num1 we can actually compare them so
down here i could say if
num1 and i can use this greater than
sign
num2 i'm basically saying if num1 is
greater than num2
then i want to do something so down here
we can set result equal to
num1 if this condition's true then we're
going to do this so only when
num1 is greater than num2 are we going
to set result equal to num1 so basically
by using this if statement we're able to
tell which one is bigger but here's the
thing what if num1 isn't greater than
num2 what if num2 is greater than num1
well i can use something called an else
statement so i can come down here and i
could say else and i don't actually need
to use an open and close parentheses i
can just make an open and close curly
bracket and the code inside of this else
block is going to execute if the
condition up here is false so if this
condition is false if num1 is not
greater than num2
then we can just
set result equal to num2
and then down here finally we're going
to return
result
so depending on whether or not this is
true result is either going to set equal
to num1 or it's going to be set equal to
num2 so let's go down here into our main
method and why don't we call this so i'm
actually going to print out the result
so i'm just going to say
printf and we're going to be printing
out an integer
and over here i'm going to call this
function so i'm just going to say max
and i'm going to pass in two numbers so
we're passing a 4 and we'll pass in a
10. so i'm passing in a 4 and i'm
passing in a 10 and this is going to
return to us whichever one is bigger
in other words this should return 10. so
let's go ahead and run our program
and you'll see over here we're returning
10. so we got the value of 10 back from
this function let's try with the other
number so let's make the first number
bigger so now we have 40 and 10 so this
should give us 40 back awesome so over
here we have an awesome function right
we're basically checking to see if num1
is greater than num2 if it is then we're
going to return num1 otherwise we're
going to return num2 and it's important
to note that even if i made these equal
so if i would've made it 40 and 40 we're
still going to get back the correct
answer so it's still going to give us 40
back so this is the basics of using if
statements right we say if we specify a
condition
if that condition's true we're going to
execute this code if that condition's
false we're going to execute this code
down here and that is an extremely
powerful structure in our programs and
we can really use this to respond to
different input right so depending on
what the user puts in num1 and num2 we
can do different things but this is just
sort of the beginning so why don't we
try to make this function a little bit
more complex so down here we're allowing
the user to input two parameters so
we're accepting two parameters into this
max function num1 and num2 and we're
able to spit out which one is bigger but
let's up the ante a little bit what if
we wanted to accept three parameters so
instead of just passing in two numbers
we wanted to be able to pass in three
numbers and have the max function spit
out the biggest so over here we can
modify this max function so i'm just
gonna make another parameter so i'm
going to say int and we'll call this one
num three so now this function is
accepting three parameters num1 num2 and
num3
but in order to figure out which one of
these is the biggest we're actually
going to need a more complex if
statement so i'm going to get rid of
this and let's just start from scratch
so let's think about this how can we
figure out which one of these is the
biggest well what i would recommend is
we could say if num1 is greater than
num2 and
num1 is greater than num3 then we know
num1 is the biggest right so if num1 is
bigger than num2 and it's bigger than
num3 we know it's the biggest if num2 is
greater than num1 and num2 is greater
than num3 then we know num2 is the
biggest and otherwise we can just say
that num 3 is the biggest so i'm going
to show you guys how to do this and
we're actually going to be introducing a
couple more concepts for if statements
so i'm just going to say if
and i want to check a condition so i
basically want to see if num1 is greater
than
or equal to num2 and num3 so down here i
can say num1 is greater than or equal to
num2
and now i also want to check to see if
num1 is greater than or equal to num3
because if num1 is greater than or equal
to num2 and it's greater than or equal
to num3 we know num1 is the biggest so i
can use this special signal here this is
called a logical operator and and
basically this is going to allow us to
put another condition in here so i could
say num one is greater than or equal to
num three
basically what this and does is it
allows us to put two conditions so we
can check two things and this whole
thing is only going to be true
if this condition's true and this
condition is true so if one of these
guys is false then this if statement
isn't going to get executed so down here
i'm just going to open this up and if
this is the case then we want to set
result
equal to num1 because if num1 is greater
than or equal to num2
and num1 is also greater than or equal
to num3 then we know num1 is the biggest
but here's the thing we also want to
check to see if num2 is the biggest so
if this is false we also want to check
to see if num2 is the biggest now we can
use something called else if so down
here i could type out else if
and i can make another open and closed
parentheses and inside of these
parentheses we can actually check
another condition so if this stuff up
here if this condition's false then
elsif is saying let's come down here
let's check another condition
so here i want to do basically the same
thing i'm going to check to see if num2
is greater than or equal to num1
and
num2 is greater than or equal to num3
so if this condition is true if num2 is
greater than or equal to num1 and it's
greater than or equal to num3 then we
know for a fact that result is going to
be num2 because that's the biggest now
finally down here we can just say else
and we can make another open and close
curly bracket and remember this code is
going to get executed when neither of
these conditions is true so here we can
just set result equal to num3
so let me walk you guys through this one
more time up here we have this if
statement
and in addition to checking to see if
num1 is greater than or equal to num2
we're also using this special operator
called and and we're checking to see if
num1 is greater than or equal to num3 if
that's the case then result is going to
be equal to num1
otherwise if this condition is false
then we're going to come down here and
we're going to check this other
condition so we're going to check to see
if num2 is bigger than num1 and if it's
bigger than num3 if that's true then
we're going to do this
finally if neither of these conditions
up here is true we're just going to go
ahead and set result equal to num3
and then we're going to return results
so this looks good to me let's test this
out and we're gonna see if it works so
now when we call max we need to include
three numbers so why don't we just do
one
two and three
and this is basically going to spit out
the biggest one which should be three so
let's run our program and you can see
over here we get three so let's try to
make one of the other ones the biggest
so we'll make the one in the first slot
the biggest and let's run this again and
you can see that it returns 10. so this
function is working so that's how we can
use these ands and we can also use else
if in order to check additional
conditions so the and is used to check
more than one condition inside of the if
parentheses and the elsif is used to
check another condition when this
conditions false and so that is actually
going to work out pretty well now i want
to show you guys a couple other things
there's a couple other things that we
can do
with these if statements so for example
i'm going to come down here and just
show you guys some of these
in addition to using that and we can
also use something called or so i'm just
going to type out a simple if statement
i could say if
3
is greater than 2 and instead of using
and like this i can use or
and or is basically going to allow us to
check two conditions and the whole thing
is going to be true if only one of those
conditions true so i could say if 3 is
greater than 2 or 2 is greater than 5.
so only one of these is true right
3 is greater than 2 that's true but 2 is
not greater than 5. so this guy is false
but when we use or only one of these two
conditions has to be true for the whole
thing to be true so if i like printed
something out here like
true
now when i run my program we should
print true because
we're using that or and you see that we
do
but if i was to make this guy false so
if i made this 3 less than 2 now it's
not going to print out true
and we can just print out false so
now we're going to end up printing out
false because both of these guys are
false
so you can see down here we're saying
false so the difference between and and
or when we have and like this
both of these conditions have to be true
in order for the whole thing to be true
and for us to execute this code
when we have or
only one of these guys has to be true so
that's kind of the difference there and
i want to show you guys a couple other
things that we can use so um over here
we're using like a less than sign so for
example if 3 is less than 2 i could also
use a greater than sign i could use a
less than or equal to sign
i could use also a greater than or equal
to sign and if i wanted to check for
equality i could use a double i could
use a double equals so the double equals
we'll check to see if three
is equal to two we can also use one more
which is this exclamation point an
exclamation point basically means not
equals so i could say if 3 is not equal
to 2 then we'll print out true so down
here let's run this and you'll see that
we get true
so yeah there you go
one more thing i want to show you is how
we can negate an entire operation so for
example if i said 3 is greater than 2
this is going to be true right so we'd
end up printing out true down here
because 3 is greater than 2.
but i could surround this whole thing
with parentheses and i could put an
exclamation point right before this
and this is called the negation operator
and it's basically going to negate
whatever this ends up being so this is
true and we put this negation operator
here this whole thing is going to be
false and so now you'll see because this
is true and we're using the negation
operator we're not going to end up
printing out true
and you can see we just don't print
anything but if i put a false condition
in here like if i said 3 is less than 2
this is false but because we're negating
it now it's going to end up being true
so when i run my program you can see
that we get true so that's sort of the
basics of using if statements and i
covered just about everything that you
can do we can use ands we can use all
these different comparison operators we
can use ors and we can use this
exclamation point to negate something
in this tutorial i'm going to teach you
guys how to build a calculator in c if
you've been following along with this
course you'll know that in the beginning
of the course we actually created a
calculator and it was very basic
calculator basically we let the user
input two numbers and we took those
numbers we added them together and we
printed the answer out onto the screen
in this tutorial i'm going to take some
of the stuff that we've learned since
then and show you guys how we can build
a fully functional four function
calculator so this calculator will be
able to add subtract multiply and divide
and we're going to let the user decide
which one they want to do so we'll let
them decide if they want to add or
subtract or whatever it's going to be
pretty cool and we're going to end up
using some of the stuff that we've
learned recently in the course like if
statements we're also going to use like
getting input from users and i'm going
to show you guys how you can get
characters as input from a user as well
so down here we want to start making our
calculator basically what i'm going to
do is i'm going to ask the user to enter
a number then i'm going to ask them to
enter an operator like plus minus
division or subtraction finally we're
going to ask them to enter in a third
number and then we'll depending on what
operator they specify so addition
subtraction whatever we will perform the
correct operation and we'll print out
the number so the first thing i want to
do is create variables where we can
store the numbers and the operators so
i'm going to make some double variables
and i'm just going to call this one num1
and then we'll make another double we'll
call it num2
and finally we'll make a variable that
will store the operator that they enter
so this is just going to be a char and
i'm just going to call it op for
operator all right so now we want to
actually get input from the user i want
to figure out what numbers they want to
use and then what operator they want to
use as well so down here why don't we
get some input the first thing i'm going
to do is i'm just going to print out a
prompt so i'm just going to say enter a
number
and now what we want to do is we want to
be able to take the number they give us
and store it inside of one of those
doubles that we created so i'm just
going to use this scanf function
f and in here i'm going to specify that
we want to get a double so remember when
we're using scan f if we want to scan
for a double we use lf and lf is going
to scan for a double and now i'm going
to use a comma and we'll put the
variable that we want to store in here
so i'm going to use this ampersand and
i'm just going to say num1 so this is
exactly what we need to do to be able to
get the user's input and store it into
num1
the next thing we want to do is get the
operator so i'm going to type out
another prompt and i'm just going to say
enter
operator basically they'll be entering
in a plus sign minus sign asterisks or
forward slash depending on what they
want to do
and again now we're going to scan for a
character now when we're scanning for a
character in scanf and i actually don't
think i've talked about this yet in this
course we want to do something special
so i want to put a percent sign and a c
but before i put percent c i want to put
a space so whenever we're getting a
character from the user using scanf we
always want to put a space right here
before percent c otherwise it's not
going to work
and again we want to store this in that
op variable so i'm just going to say op
and one more time we're going to get
another number so i'm just going to copy
this
paste this down here
and
we're going to get this one for num2
so now we should have all of the input
for our program so i'm getting the first
number i'm getting the operator and i'm
getting the second number the last thing
we have to do now is actually do the
math so we're going to have to figure
out
which operator they wanted to use right
so we have this op variable and this is
storing like a plus sign a minus sign a
asterisk or a forward slash so depending
on what that's storing we want to print
something different out so we can
actually use an if statement to do this
so i can use an if statement to check
and see
what operator is inside of our operator
variable and depending on which one it
is we can do a different operation so i
can say if and the first thing i'm going
to do is just check to see if the
operator is equal to
a plus sign
so if the operator that the user entered
is equal to a plus sign then we're going
to want to add the two numbers together
so i'm just going to print out these two
numbers and i'll just say num1 plus num2
because we're going to add both of them
together we can also use an elsif so i'm
going to want to check a few other
conditions i'm going to check to see if
the operator is equal to
a minus sign and if the operator is
equal to a minus sign then instead of
adding the numbers we're going to
subtract them so over here i'll just
copy this and we'll paste this guy down
here so it's going to be num1 minus num2
and i can actually just copy this whole
thing and we'll paste it down here so
let me make some more room down here
we'll paste this other elsif
and here we're going to check to see if
it's division so we'll check for a
forward slash and again we're just going
to want to print out a decimal number so
it's going to be num1 divided by num2
finally we're going to check for
multiplication so if it's multiplication
then we're going to multiply them
together so now we're checking for each
of the operators we're checking for
addition subtraction multiplication and
division but here's the thing what
happens if the user enters in an
operator that we didn't want so for
example if they don't enter in any of
these operators we're going to want to
tell them so i'm going to have this like
print out a little error message i'm
just going to say else and basically the
code inside this else block will get
executed if none of these conditions up
here are true and down here we can just
make a printf and i'm just going to
print out invalid
operator
so now we have our if statement our if
block setup and this should be
everything that we need to use our
little calculator
all right so let's go ahead and run this
program so you can see over here it says
enter a number so we can enter a number
let's enter in 5.9
and enter an operator we'll add numbers
and now let's enter in 4.0 so we're
going to add 5.9 and 4. so when i click
enter we should go through all of those
if statements and figure out what we
need to do and you'll see over here that
we're adding 5.9 and 4 together and
we're getting 9.9 so looks like the
program worked let's try it again we'll
try another operator why don't we try to
multiply some numbers so let's multiply
6
and
times i don't know 5.7
so we get 34.2 that seems about right
all right and then one more time we'll
run this and i want to try to enter in
an invalid operator so we'll say like
5.7
and i'm just going to enter in a g so
that's an invalid operator that's not
going to work
and i'll enter my number let's do eight
and you can see it tells us invalid
operator so basically we have a four
function calculator this calculator can
multiply divide subtract and add and if
you don't enter in a correct operator
it's smart enough to yell at you and
tell you that you have an invalid
operator so
this seems to work pretty well i'm
pretty happy with it and you can see
down here like this is a perfect
situation for using something like an if
statement right we have this variable op
right it's storing some sort of operator
we don't necessarily know what's inside
of there but i can use if statements and
i can respond to the different scenarios
so in the situation where it's a plus
sign i can respond in a situation where
it's a minus sign i can respond etc and
this just makes our programs a lot
smarter and it helps us to do different
things when different situations arise
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about using switch statements in c
now a switch statement is basically a
special type of if statement which will
allow us to compare one value to a bunch
of different values and it's essentially
doing the same thing as an if statement
it's allowing us to check different
conditions and if different conditions
are true then we can do certain things
but a switch statement makes it really
really easy for us to compare one
specific value to a bunch of other
values i'm gonna show you guys how we
can use that in this tutorial to make a
little test app so i'm gonna build a
little program that will take a letter
grade and depending on the letter grade
it will tell you whether or not you did
good or bad on a test so if you got an a
on the test it would say hey you did a
good job if you got a b on a test it'd
be like hey you did all right if you got
an f on the test to tell you that you
failed the test so we're basically going
to have a variable where we'll store a
grade that you would have gotten on test
and we'll be able to respond to that
grade using a switch statement so it's
going to be pretty cool so down here the
first thing i'm going to do is create a
variable and it's just going to be a
character i'm just going to call it
grade
and i'm going to set it equal to
a so we're going to say that whoever
took this test got an a on the test and
they did really well
now what i want to do is i want to
create a switch statement so i'm just
going to say
switch and i'm going to make an open and
close parentheses and inside of this
parentheses i'm going to put grade so
i'm just going to put grade
and i'm going to make an open and close
curly bracket so this is sort of like
the basic structure for our switch
statement now here's what i'm basically
going to do i'm going to take this
variable here that i passed into the
parentheses grade
and i'm going to compare it to a bunch
of different values so i'm going to take
this and i'm going to see if it's equal
to one value then i'm going to see if
it's equal to a different value or a
different value or a different value and
depending on the value that it ends up
being equal to we're going to do
something different and these are what
are called cases so down here i can say
case
and i just want to type out a
character so for example i could put a
right here and then i'm going to put a
colon
and when i put a right here basically
what this is saying is in the case that
grade is equal to a
then i'm going to put some code down
here that i want to execute so i could
just put like a print statement
and i could say like you did great
because they did great on the test and
basically
what this is saying is in the case that
the grade is equal to a we're going to
print this out and then i want to put
one more thing down here which is called
break and i'm going to explain what
break does in a second
so i could make one of these little case
statements for every possibility so for
every possible grade that we could get
so i'm actually just going to copy this
whole thing
and i'm going to paste it down here
so now i can put a b in here so we're
saying in the case that the grade is
equal to b i'm going to say you did all
right
and then we're also going to break
and down here i'm going to make another
one so i'll say case and this time we'll
make it c
in the case that they get a c i'm going
to print out
poorly
and there's a couple more that we can
check so we can check if they got a d or
an f so in the case
they got a d
and i forgot to put a break statement
here
and i'm gonna put one down here too and
finally we're just gonna do one more for
if they failed the test so i'm just
going to say in the case that they got
an f
we will print out
you failed
so
essentially what i'm doing here is i'm
writing out all of these different cases
so i'm saying in the case that you got
an f i'm going to print out you failed
in the case they got a d i'm going to
print out you did very bad and then we
also have this break statement here and
this break statement basically tells our
switch statement that we want to leave
so whenever we're executing this switch
statement whenever c is executing the
switch statement it's checking to see if
grade is equal to each one of these
cases so for example let's say the grade
is equal to a it's going to execute this
print f but if i don't put this break
statement in here then it's just going
to keep going and keep checking these
different cases so it's always important
to put a break statement in there
because i basically just want to break
out of this switch statement i don't
want to be in here anymore so finally we
can check one more thing in the case
that the user
or that we get an invalid grade so for
example someone entered in like a t or a
g or something that's not a valid grade
so i can use something called default
and default is basically like an else so
default is going to execute
whenever none of these conditions up
here are met so then i can just put
something like
invalid grade or something
and this will basically be like hey you
got an invalid grade
so let's take a look at this switch
statement and we'll just kind of talk a
little bit more about what it's doing
basically i'm passing this in a variable
or a value or something
and i'm going to check this value
against all of these different
conditions so in the case the grade is
equal to a we're going to print you did
great in the case that b is equal to
grade will print you did alright etc and
this is basically doing what an if
statement's doing so i could replicate
this entire statement this entire switch
statement as an if statement i could
write out if etc else if else if else if
but this just makes it a lot easier so i
don't have to constantly write out all
of that if statement stuff
so hopefully we did everything right and
let's actually check and see how our
program does
so
grade is equal to a let's run our
program and see what our message is
it says hey you did great because we got
an a
if i made this an f instead of an a
now it should tell us that we failed
so it says you failed if i made this a c
it'll tell us that we did poorly and it
says you did poorly so this is a super
easy way for us to check one single
value against a bunch of different
conditions and that's really the point
of a switch statement is you're checking
one single value like grade
against a bunch of other values and
that's where it can be extremely useful
so consider using the switch statements
they're not appropriate in every
situation and there's i'd say like very
select few situations where switch
statements will come in handy but when
they are appropriate switch statements
will save you a lot of time and a lot of
hassle
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about structs in c
now a struct is a data structure where
we can store
groups of data types so inside of a
struct i could store like an integer
alongside of a string alongside a
character alongside a double i can store
all these different data types in one
single data structure and there's tons
of uses for structs and one of the
things we can do with them is model real
world entities so i could basically like
model uh something in the real world
inside of my program and i'm going to
show you guys how to do that in this
tutorial we're going to be looking at
how we can use a struct to represent a
student inside of our program so imagine
we were writing a piece of software that
was using like students so it was like
storing records of students or something
i could use a struct to represent a
student in my program so over here
in my program i'm just going to come up
here above the main method and i'm
actually going to create a struct you
guys will see like how these work and
how we can use them so i'm just going to
say
struct
and over here i'm going to give this a
name so i'm going to call this
student and a lot of times in c when
we're making structs you're going to
give them a capital letter just like
that
and i'm going to make an open and closed
curly bracket now inside of this struct
i can start specifying what types of
data are going to make up a student in
my program so basically i can define
like different attributes of a student
and place them in here and this will
kind of act as a template you'll see how
we can use this later
so let's think about different
attributes of a student well one thing
would be like the student's name so i
could say char name and i'm going to
make this a array of characters
so this is going to represent the name
and actually why don't we give this a
number so i'm going to say 50. so this
string can hold 50 characters maximum
and now we're going to make another one
for major so we're going to want to
store the students major and again we'll
make this 50.
i also want to make an integer for the
student's age
and a double for the student's gpa
so i have this struct student and in
here i have a bunch of attributes of a
student right i have like the student's
name their major
an integer that stores their age and a
double for their gpa essentially what i
did was i created like a type of student
data type so i basically am allowing
myself now to represent a student inside
of my program so let's come down here to
this main method and i'll show you guys
how we can use this so i can basically
create an instance of this student
structure so i can create like an actual
student
inside of my program and the way that i
do that is just by saying struct and i
want to type out the name of the struct
that i want to make
in our case it's going to be a student
and i want to give this a name so i'm
just going to call it student1
and i can just use a semicolon here
basically what i did now was i created a
container called student one that's
going to be able to store
a name a major an age and a gpa
so if you're familiar with arrays in c
you'll know an array is a special
structure that can hold multiple pieces
of information but all of the pieces of
information inside of an array need to
be of the same data type and also they
don't have names with a struct i can
have a bunch of different data types
like this and i can also give them names
like name major age and gpa so let me
show you guys how we can assign some
values to these so for this particular
student student one i can give them a
name i can give them a major a gpa and
an age so i could say
student1.age
and i can set this equal to something so
i could say let's say student one's age
is 22. so basically inside of this
student one container i'm saying the age
of this particular student is going to
be 22. i can do the same for the gpa so
i can say student.gpa is equal to maybe
they have a 3.2 so i'm saying this
particular student's gpa is a 3.2
i can also do the same thing for those
strings so for the name and the major
now here's the thing about working with
strings remember in c a string is
actually just an array of characters
and when we have an array we can't like
give it a particular value so for
example if i wanted to give this
student's name a value this is just an
array of characters so i can't just come
down here and say student dot name is
equal to something that's not going to
work because you can't do that with an
array i can use something called the
string copy function and this is a
function that will take a string and
it'll give it a value that we specify so
it'll basically do
what we want to do like what we did over
here with the age and the gpa but with
the name so i can say like str cpy and
inside of here i need to pass this two
parameters the first thing i want to
pass is the destination for the string
so we're going to pass in
student1.name the second thing i want to
pass in is the
string that i want to store
inside of student1.name so in our case
let's just name it him jim
so now we have the student1.names value
is equal to jim and i can do the same
thing for major so i'm just going to
copy this and we'll come down here
and i can say
dot major and we're gonna set this equal
to
business so let's say jim is a business
major
essentially what i've done here is i've
created a student and that student had
all the attributes that we defined up
here so this particular student had a
name a major an age and a gpa
and i gave all of those values so i
assigned this student one
an age of 22 a gpa of 3.2 etc so now
what i can actually do is i can print
out all these different values that are
stored inside of this structure so if i
wanted for example i could like
print out the gpa so i could print out
student1.gpa
and now we're going to be printing out
3.2 and actually it looks like i have a
typo here this should be student one not
student
all right so here we're printing out 3.2
so we're printing out the value of the
student's gpa i can also print out like
their name so why don't we do that
student1 dot name and now this is going
to print out jim
so you see we printed out over there so
a struct is a really useful structure
and another cool thing we can do with
structs is we could actually create
another student so i could create like
another instance of that student
structure
so i'm actually just going to copy all
this stuff i'll show you how we can do
this i'll just come down here and paste
it
and instead of student one why don't we
call this one student two
and we can set this student's age to be
like maybe 20 maybe their gpa is a 2.5
let's say their name is pam and they're
studying art
so now i have a completely different
student and if i wanted i could print
out this student's attribute so i could
print out like student two
dot name and now we're gonna get pam
instead of jim so you can see how that
works right there
so i could create as many of these
students as i want and this is what's
cool about structs is i can just define
the basic template for a student in my
program and then i can create individual
students down here that i can work with
so now i have this like student variable
here i could do whatever i want with it
i could pass it into a function
i could print it out onto the screen i
could use it in something like an if
statement i could do basically anything
i want with it it's it acts a lot like a
variable or an array so remember
variables and arrays are just containers
we can do just about anything we want
with them and that's the same with a
struct so this has just been kind of an
introduction and what you could do as an
exercise is think of other things you
might want to model in your program so
maybe something like a book or something
like a phone you could model a phone
using a struct you know basically any
type of
information you could store using a
struct just like this
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about while loops in c
now a while loop is basically a
structure in the c programming language
that we can use to loop over and
continually execute a specific block of
code until a certain condition is false
so i can specify a condition and then i
can basically just loop over a bunch of
code until that condition is no longer
true
and loops can be really useful there's a
lot of times in our programs where we're
going to want to like continually do
something while something else is true
or while a certain condition uh is met
and i'm gonna show you guys a really
basic while loop in this tutorial and
then in the next tutorial we're actually
gonna build a really cool guessing game
using while loops so it should be pretty
fun and you should get a pretty good
idea of like how these things work
the first thing i want to do
and this isn't directly related to
creating a while loop though is i want
to create an integer so i'm just going
to create an integer called index and
i'm going to set it equal to 1.
now what i want to do is i want to
actually create a while loop and you
guys will see where this index comes
into play so in order to create a while
loop i can just type out while and open
and close parentheses and then an open
and close curly bracket and this is
basically like the outline sort of like
the template for our while loop
basically how this is going to work is
up here in these parentheses i'm going
to specify a condition
and as long as that condition is true
i'm going to loop through all of the
code inside of these curly brackets so
inside of these curly brackets i'm going
to put a bunch of code and as long as
the condition in these parentheses is
true i'm going to execute all that code
so up here we're going to specify a
condition i'm going to specify a
condition that index
is less than or equal to five
so while index is less than or equal to
five i wanna execute all the code inside
of here so i'm gonna put some code in
here the first thing i'm gonna do is i'm
just gonna print out the value of
index so over here
i'm just going to say
we want to print out an integer
and i'm just going to print out index so
we'll be printing out index and actually
why don't we print out a new line every
time too
there we go
and finally after this i want to
increment the index variable so i can
just say index is equal to index plus
one
basically i'm adding one onto the index
every time actually i want to show you
guys something and see there's going to
be a lot of situations where you're
going to want to do something like this
basically add one to an existing
variable and in c there's actually a
shortcut we can use so i can come over
here and i can just say index plus plus
and this is going to do the same thing
so this is just going to add one to the
index
essentially what i'm doing is i'm saying
i want to print out index and then i
want to increment index and i'm going to
keep looping through this code
while index is less than or equal to
five so let's go ahead and run this
program and maybe you can predict what's
gonna happen
you'll see over here i'm printing out
the numbers one through five
so i'm printing out one two three four
and five and let me walk you guys
through exactly what's happening in this
loop over here we create this index
variable and we set it equal to one
and basically when c goes to execute
this program the first thing it's going
to do before it does anything else is
it's going to look at this condition and
it's going to check the condition and
it's gonna say okay is index less than
or equal to five well the first time
through index is equal to one so it's
definitely less than five c is going to
go through it's gonna execute this line
of code printing out one then it's gonna
execute this line of code incrementing
index then what c is going to do is it's
going to come all the way back up here
and it's going to check this condition
again so it's going to say okay is index
less than or equal to 5 and index at
this point is equal to 2 so it's less
than five so it's going to go through
execute this line of code execute this
line of code now index is equal to three
and c is going to go all the way back up
to the top it's gonna check this
condition again so before c goes through
this loop it's always going to it's
always going to check the condition
first so before it's allowed to go and
execute that code again it has to check
the condition to make sure that it's
true
eventually we're going to get to a
situation where index gets incremented
and it gets incremented up to six
then c is gonna come back up here and
it's gonna check to see if six
is less than or equal to five it's gonna
be false and we're gonna move on with
our lives in the program and that's the
basics of while loops so this seems very
simple and that's because it is all we
do is specify a condition as long as
that condition's true we keep doing all
this stuff in here
and there's tons of situations where
while loops are going to come in handy
this is just one of them where we can
print out like numbers between 1 and 5.
i also do want to point out one thing
that you might want to watch out for
which is called an infinite loop and an
infinite loop is a situation where this
condition up here never becomes false
so this condition will just always stay
true and there's certain circumstances
where you're going to want to use
something like an infinite loop but in a
lot of circumstances you're not going to
want to go anywhere near something like
that so let me just demonstrate so you
guys can see so if i stopped
incrementing this if i just got rid of
index plus plus
now when i run my program you'll see
that it's just continually printing out
ones i mean look at all these ones that
are getting printed out you can see like
the text editor is kind of going crazy
this program is just it keeps executing
through that loop and it's still going
right now so this would keep going
forever if i let it keep going
infinitely hence the name so i'm just
going to terminate this but that'll kind
of show you like uh how an infinite loop
works and you definitely want to watch
out for that because you'll get into
situations as you work with while loops
where they'll just become infinite and
you you know you need to watch out for
that especially if you're doing
something a little bit more advanced
where you're like siphoning off memory
or you're creating processes or
something it can
slow your computer down quite a bit so
this is a while loop and this is a
really great loop there's also one other
type of loop uh that's similar to a
while loop that i want to talk to you
guys about and before i do that i just
want to do something really quick so i'm
going to set this
index equal to 6. right i'm going to set
this equal to 6 and i'm going to run my
program and what you're going to notice
is
nothing is going to get printed out so
the code inside of this while loop isn't
going to print out because the first
thing we always do when we run this
while loop is we check this condition so
the first thing c is going to do before
it prints anything before it increments
anything it's going to check this
condition and if it's false it's not
going to do any of this stuff so when i
run this program
you'll see nothing is going to get
printed out and that's exactly what
happens
there's another type of loop that's
similar to a while loop which is called
a do while loop and i'm going to show
you how to make one all you have to do
is take this while thing up here and
paste it down here below
and then up here i'm just going to say
do
and a do while loop is similar to a
while loop but the first thing a do
while loop does instead of checking this
condition down here is it executes all
of this code so even though index is
equal to six we're still going to print
out six and we're still going to
increment it and then we're gonna check
the condition to see if we can keep
looping so let me show you guys this and
this should illustrate what this is
doing and actually i need to put a
semicolon here
so you can see over here we're printing
out six so unlike before when we just
use that while loop now because we're
using a do while loop we're doing
whatever was inside of that loop before
we're checking the condition
and there's going to be certain
circumstances where a do while loop will
uh come in handy i would say by far
while loops are way more common
but just you know it's good to know
about do while loops because there are
certain circumstances where they'll come
in handy basically anytime you don't
want to be checking the condition first
you can use a do while loop but those
are the two basic types and there's
actually another type of loop that we'll
talk about later in the course which is
called a for loop but for now we're
going to have some fun with while loops
and in the next tutorial we're going to
be building a little guessing game
in this tutorial i'm going to teach you
guys how to build a little guessing game
in c this is going to be pretty cool
because we're going to use a lot of the
stuff that we've learned up to this
point in the course in order to build it
so let's get started basically this
guessing game is going to allow the user
to guess a secret number so we're going
to define a secret number and we're
going to give the user the opportunity
to try and guess it so if they'll try to
guess it if they get it right then
they'll win the game and if they don't
get it right then we'll let them guess
again right so we'll basically let them
keep guessing what the secret number is
until they get it
so down here we want to create a couple
variables the first variable i want to
create is going to be an integer and
it's going to be the secret number so
i'm just going to call it secret number
and why don't we just set it equal to 5.
the next variable we want to create is
going to store the user's guess so this
is also going to be an integer and i'm
just going to call it guess and i'm not
going to give it a value yet because
right off the bat the user wouldn't have
guessed a number
so what we want to do is we want to be
able to prompt the user to enter in the
number until they get it right so as
long as the user hasn't entered in the
correct number we want to keep asking
them to enter it in in order to do that
in order to like keep asking them to
enter it until they've guessed it we can
use something called a while loop so i'm
just going to type while
and i'm going to make an open and close
parentheses and an open and closed curly
brackets let's think about a good
condition for our game basically we want
to keep asking the user to enter an
input as long as they haven't guessed
the secret number so it's right there we
could keep looping as long as the guess
is not equal to
the secret number right and basically
this is always going to be true until
they guess the correct number now inside
of here we want to prompt them to enter
their guess and then we want to take
whatever they enter and store it inside
of our guess variable so
let's do this first we'll say printf and
i'm just going to say
enter a number
and then down here i'm going to use
scan f in order to
get whatever number they enter and i'm
going to store it
inside of that guess variable so i'm
just going to say at guess
and this is going to take whatever
number whatever integer they enter and
it's going to store it inside of our
guess variable so basically what's
happening in this loop is every time
through the loop we're getting a
different number and then we're going to
come up here and we're going to check to
see if it's equal to the secret number
if it's not then we're going to go
through again and we're going to keep
doing this but if the guess is equal to
the secret number then we'll break out
of the loop and that means we'll be down
here
so i'm just going to print out a success
message and i'll basically just say like
hey you win
all right awesome so you can see this
isn't actually that many lines of code i
mean it's probably like 10 lines of code
to write out this whole thing and it
looks like everything's set up so this
should actually work properly so let's
try to run this and we'll see if we can
guess the secret number so remember
secret number is five
so i'm gonna run the program it says
enter a number so let's just kind of
botch the guesses two
seven eight nine
three so you'll notice i can keep
entering in numbers
and it'll keep prompting me to enter a
number as long as i haven't guessed it
correctly so now let's type in 5 and
remember 5 is the secret number when i
click enter now that loop condition is
going to end up being false right
because the guess is going to be equal
to the secret number and it's going to
execute and it's going to say hey you
win right so we broke out of that loop
we executed the print statement that
said you win and the program terminated
and that is a really cool little game so
one of the cool things about this game
and it's different from programs that
we've written in this course in the past
is it'll keep running
essentially infinitely until we enter in
that correct guess so it's going to keep
going and keep going and keep asking us
to do something and to enter in a value
until we entered correctly so this is
pretty cool
now this is a pretty nice game and it's
it's pretty simple but i want to maybe
make it a little more complex one of the
things that sucks about our game right
now
is that the user gets unlimited guesses
right so basically like
they can just guess every single number
and eventually they're gonna get it
right you know
so why don't we do this we should impose
a guess limit so why don't we say like
the user can only guess three times and
if they can't get the secret number in
three tries then they'll lose the game
so let's think about how we can go ahead
and add that functionality into this
little app i'm going to walk you guys
through how we can do that the first
thing we're going to need to do is we're
going to need to create some variables
i'm going to create another variable up
here and i'm just going to call it guess
count
and guess count is basically going to
tell us how many times the user has
tried to guess the secret number and i'm
just going to set this equal to zero
because initially the user will have
guessed zero times so remember this
guest count variable is basically going
to get incremented every time they guess
right so i'm going to come down here
every time we go through this loop the
user is guessing so every time we go
through this loop i'm going to increment
the guest count so i'm just going to say
guess count plus plus and that means
every time the user guesses the guess
count will get incremented and we'll
have a accurate
count of how many times the user has
guessed
all right the second variable that i
want to make is going to be another
integer and i'm just going to call it
guess limit and this is going to tell us
how many times the user can guess so
this will basically determine like how
many guesses the user gets so why don't
we set this equal to three i think three
guesses is a pretty good limit and
finally we wanna create one more
variable and this is also gonna be an
integer and i'm just gonna call this out
of
guesses and i'm gonna set out of guesses
equal to
zero and out of guesses will basically
tell us whether or not the user has any
more guesses and this might not be super
clear what this is doing right now
but keep following the video and you'll
see how this comes into play this is
actually going to be really important so
we're actually going to have to modify
our code a little bit so down here we
have this set up so the user can keep
guessing as long as the guess isn't
equal to the secret number but we want
to be able to limit the amount of times
that the user can guess and actually
down here i'm going to create an if
statement and every time we go through
this loop i want to check and see if the
user has any more guesses left i want in
other words i want to see if they've
reached their guess limit or not so i'm
going to make an if statement and i'm
going to check to see if the guess count
is less than
the guess limit
as long as the guess count is less than
the guess limit that means they haven't
guessed as many times as the limit
specifies basically they can guess again
right so down here inside of this if
statement i'm going to put all of this
code and i'm just going to surround this
with curly brackets
so basically the user can only guess the
number this code will only get executed
when
the guest count is less than the guess
limit when the user has additional
guesses right when they haven't guessed
as many times as the limit specifies
otherwise though so if they have guessed
too many times right if the guess count
is either equal to or greater than the
guess limit i'm actually going to set
this out of guesses variable equal to 1.
so i'm going to say
out of
guesses is equal to one and basically
what this is going to tell us is if out
of guesses is greater than zero then
that'll tell us that the user is out of
guesses so essentially if out of guesses
has a value that's more than zero will
know that they've run out of guesses
and if you've ever used any other
programming languages before this is
what we refer to as like a boolean
variable it's basically storing like a
true or a false value which we're
representing with zero or one so
if the guess counts less than the guess
limit they can guess again otherwise
we're gonna say out of guesses is equal
to one in other words we're going to say
that they're out of guesses there's one
more thing we have to do though is we
have to come up here and we have to
change this condition because right now
we're going to keep looping through this
code as long as the guess is not equal
to the secret number
but there's actually two situations
where we want to break out of the loop
the first is when they've guessed the
number correctly right then we want to
come down here and print out you win
but we also want to break out of the
loop when they've run out of guesses so
i want to check to see whether or not
they're out of guesses so i'm going to
say guess is not equal to secret number
and out of
guesses
is equal to zero so as long as out of
guesses is equal to zero that means that
they're not out of guesses and they
still have some guesses left but if the
guess counts less than the guess limit
and out of guesses gets set equal to one
then out of guesses isn't going to be
equal to zero anymore so we're going to
break out of the loop so basically
there's two scenarios now that will
break us out of the loop either they get
the word right or they run out of
guesses
so one more thing we have to do in this
program is come down here and you'll see
down here we're always printing out you
win so no matter what like no matter
what happens
we're printing out you win and that's
because before
if they made it down here if they made
it out of that loop that means that they
guessed the secret number correctly but
there's actually two scenarios down here
where they would have broken out of the
loop where they're either out of guesses
or they guessed the secret word so i
want to actually check to see which one
we're dealing with so i'm going to check
to see if
out of guesses and i'm going to check to
see if it's equal to 1
and if it's equal to 1
that means that they lost and they ran
out of guesses so i'm just gonna say
out of
guesses
otherwise though it means that they won
so i'm gonna say
you win and this will basically be like
hey you won the game
awesome
so this is a lot of code i know that um
and let's just run this see how we did
and we'll see if our game's working
properly and then i'll kind of explain
all the code to you guys
and actually you know what i just
noticed a typo down here i said out of
guesses double equals one this is just
has to be a single equals so we're
assigning this a value so yeah that was
a little typo i had two equals that
needs to be one
so let's go over here we'll run our
program and it says enter a number so
why don't we try to lose the game i'm
just going to say two two
and now we're on our third and final
guess if i don't get it this time that
means we're going to lose the game so
i'm going to enter and you'll see it
says out of guesses so we weren't able
to guess it within our three tries and
the game told us that we lost let's run
it one more time we'll try to win so
i'll say like two one
now we're on our third and final guess
so if i don't get it this time we're
gonna lose i'm gonna guess a five and we
guessed right so it's gonna tell us that
we won so that's sort of basically how
this little program works and i'm gonna
walk you guys through one more time so
we have all these variables up here
secret number
is just storing the number they need to
guess the guest keeps track of what
they're guessing each time
the guest count is going to tell us how
many times they've guessed the number
guess limit is going to tell us how many
times they can guess
and out of guesses is going to tell us
whether or not the user is out of
guesses so down here we're checking two
conditions for this while loop we're
checking to see if the guess is not
equal to the secret number
and we're gonna keep looping as long as
out of guesses is equal to zero every
time we go through this loop we check to
see if the guess count is less than the
guess limit if it is
then we ask them to guess we increment
the guest count
otherwise we say out of guesses is equal
to one and that's going to break us out
of the loop down here there's two
situations the first situation is that
they ran out of guesses the second
situation is that they won the game and
we're using this if statement to check
both of those so
that's basically how this works and this
kind of shows you how we can use things
like while loops and if statements and
also variables together in like one
single program
in this tutorial i'm going to teach you
guys how to use for loops in c now a for
loop is a special type of loop that we
can use in c which allows us to use
something called an indexing variable
and this indexing variable will
basically tell us what iteration of the
loop we're currently on and we can use
that indexing variable to do a bunch of
stuff like we could loop through an
array of items we could do all sorts of
stuff inside of a loop so down here in
my program you'll see that i have a
while loop set up and i have just sort
of a basic while loop and i want to show
you guys what it's doing so essentially
up here i'm saying int i is equal to one
so i'm giving this integer i the value
of one and i'm saying while
i is less than or equal to five
i'm going to print out the value of i
and then i'm going to increment i so
this is a very simple while loop
basically we have this variable i and
every time we go through the loop we're
printing it out until it's
greater than five so let's run this
program and we'll see what it does
so you'll see over here we're basically
printing out values between one and five
and i want to point out what's actually
happening so the first time that we go
through this while loop we're printing
out one
the second time we're printing out two
the third time we're printing out three
in other words this variable i
is basically telling us what iteration
of the loop we're currently on
so on the first iteration of the loop i
is telling us that we're on the first
iteration of the loop right the first
time we go through the loop i is equal
to one second time we go through the
loop i is equal to two third time i is
equal to three so this variable i over
here is basically telling us how many
times we've gone through the loop so on
the third time it's telling us three
fourth time four etc and believe it or
not this is actually a very useful thing
for us to have when we're looping and
there's a lot of situations where you're
going to want to know what iteration of
the loop you're currently on
when you're looping so with a normal
while loop like i can basically just
specify a condition up here and i can do
whatever i want right it's very open you
can kind of just do whatever you want
with it but
in a lot of situations and there's tons
of these situations we're going to want
to have a variable just like i that will
tell us what iteration of the loop that
we're currently on or you know basically
just a variable that's going to keep
changing every time we go through the
loop and this is such a common situation
in c that there's actually something
called a for loop and a for loop allows
us to take all of this code and condense
it into its own single loop so it's
taking this situation where we want to
have a variable like i
and it's basically allowing us to do it
a lot easier and a lot cleaner so i'm
going to show you guys how we can create
a for loop
i'm going to come down here below this
while loop and i'm going to create a
basic four loop structure so i'm just
going to say four i'm going to make an
open and close parentheses and an open
and closed curly bracket
now the difference between a for loop
and a while loop is
basically going to happen inside of
these parentheses so in the parenthesis
of a while loop we have our loop
condition or our loop guard right this
is specifying whether or not we can keep
looping through
inside this for loop we're going to have
three different things so instead of
just one loop guard we're actually going
to have three different things that we
want to put inside of here so with a for
loop the first thing i'm going to put in
here is this variable i so you'll notice
in the while loop we have our variable i
up here and this is basically allowing
us to loop through and keep track of how
many times we've gone through the loop
so what i can do down here is i can do
something similar i could say like int i
and i'm not going to give this a value
inside of here i'm going to say i is
equal to 1. so basically i'm going to
take my variable i and i'm going to give
it an initial value of 1. and now i have
my i variable i have my variable that's
going to change every time we go through
the loop
the next thing i want to do is include
my looping condition so up here we have
i is less than or equal to 5 that's our
condition i can put the same thing down
here so i'm going to say i is less than
or equal to 5.
the third thing i want to do is
increment i so you'll notice down here
every time we go through this loop we're
incrementing that variable i i'm going
to do the same thing over here in this
little third quadrant so you'll notice i
have these little like sections here's
the first section we're initializing the
variable i we're saying i is equal to
one
here we're specifying our looping
conditions so i'm saying we're going to
keep looping while i is less than or
equal to five and over here is a little
line of code that's gonna get executed
every time we go through the loop so
here i'm saying i plus plus i could also
say like i minus minus and that would
decrement i
i could say like i is equal to i plus 2
etc like i could do basically anything i
wanted over here let's just keep it at i
plus plus for now so you'll see i was
basically able to take all of this code
and condense it into its own little type
of loop and now instead of having to
like print this out and create this
variable up here i can do all of that
inside of this for loop now i can
basically take this line of code i can
paste it down into here
and we essentially have the same thing
so
right now this block of code and this
block of code are 100 equivalent they're
doing exactly the same thing so let's go
ahead and get rid of all this code and
let's test out our shiny new for loop so
i'm just gonna run my program and you'll
see over here we're getting exactly the
same thing that we got before we're
printing out one two three four five so
it's the same exact program doing the
same exact thing
and that's why for loops are great
because we can take that little
structure like where we have an indexing
variable and we can use it with
something like this so i want to show
you another situation where these for
loops can come in handy and we can use
them to loop through all the elements
inside of an array so actually up here i
have this array that i created it's
called lucky numbers and i'm just going
to grab this and bring it down here
so we have this lucky numbers array it
has 4 8 15 16 23 42
and what i could actually do is i could
loop through all of the elements inside
of this array
from this for loop so i'm going to show
you guys how we can do that now let's
first off see how many elements we have
we have one two three four five six so
we have six elements
in this array so
what i'm gonna do is i'm actually gonna
say i is equal to zero and you'll see
why we need to do this in a second but
basically array indexes start at zero so
this first element in the array is at
index position zero and just for a
little refresher if i wanted to access
one of these elements from inside the
array i could say like lucky numbers
was zero and this is going to give me
access to
this element if i said lucky numbers 2
then i'll get access to this element
this 15. so this is basically how we can
access an element inside the array so
i'm going to set i equal to 0 and i'm
going to say i want to loop while i is
less than six
and six was how how many elements we had
in the array so i want to keep looping
as long as we're less than six and i'm
gonna say i plus plus
now down here i'm gonna do this same
exact thing but instead of printing out
i i'm going to print out lucky
numbers
i
so i'm going to print out the array
element at index position i and lucky
numbers
basically the first time we go through
this loop we're going to be printing out
lucky numbers 0 because i is going to be
equal to 0. the second time we go
through the loop we're going to be
printing out lucky numbers 1 because i
is going to be equal to 1 etc and we're
going to keep doing that until we get
all the way up to five which is going to
be the last element which is this 42.
so let's go ahead and do that so i need
to put this back to i
and let's run this program so you'll see
over here we're basically doing exactly
what i said so the first time through
the loop we're printing out four we're
printing out that first element the
second time through the loop we're
printing out eight which is the second
element
15 16 23 and 42 so we're printing out
all of those elements in turn as we go
through this for loop and
there's a lot of situations where for
loops are going to come in handy but
this is a very very very very common
situation where we want to loop through
all the elements in an array and either
print them out or you know do something
to them whatever so that's the basics of
working with for loops and i do just
want to say like anything that you do
with a for loop you could do with a
while loop you know i basically showed
you guys how we transformed that while
loop into a for loop the thing with for
loops though is that they're very
convenient so it makes it really easy to
do something like this without having to
go through all the trouble of creating a
while loop
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about two topics in c the first
topic we're going to talk about are
two-dimensional arrays a two-dimensional
array is basically a situation where we
have an array where all of the elements
in the array are actually arrays
themselves
the second thing i want to talk to you
guys about is nested loops so we're
going to look at how we can use a
looping structure where we have a loop
inside of a loop so it's going to be
pretty cool and actually these two
topics can go together really well and
i'm going to show you guys how we can
use nested loops and two-dimensional
arrays in order to make an awesome
program so let's get started the first
thing i want to show you guys is
two-dimensional arrays
so down here we can create a 2d array
and actually the concepts that i'm
showing you in this video can apply to
multi-dimensional arrays so not only two
dimensions but three four five really as
many dimensions as your heart desires so
in order to create a two-dimensional
array i'm just gonna make an array of
numbers so i'm just gonna say inch and
we'll give this a name so why don't we
just say nums
and
normally when we create an array after
we'd say the name of the array we'd make
an open and close square bracket
but when we create a two-dimensional
array we're going to make two open and
closed square brackets just like that
these two open and closed square
brackets will basically represent like
the
width and the height of our array so you
guys will see what i mean in a second
but basically we're going to have like
elements in the array and then each of
those elements is going to be an array
and we'll have elements inside of it so
these two squares will allow us to like
manipulate all that stuff so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to set this
equal to
an open enclosed curly bracket now this
is normally how we would create an array
so normally i would just say like one
two three four or whatever i could put
all my numbers in here but with a
two-dimensional array all of the
elements are gonna be arrays so instead
of just saying like one two three
we're actually going to create
arrays inside of here so for example
i'll put an array right here
and this text editor is so annoying with
making these
so for example the first element in this
array i could just make an array so i'm
going to say this is like one two so you
can see here i have two elements
inside of this array which is itself the
first element of the nums array so let's
make another one i'm gonna come down
here and we'll make another one and this
keeps trying to format differently
so now we're gonna say three four
so this thing right here this whole
array that's the first element in the
nums array right and that array has two
elements inside of it same thing with
this one this is the second element in
the nums array and it has two elements
inside of it so it's basically an array
within an array
let's make one more
and so this is going to be five six
so now we have three array elements
right one
two
three and each of them has two elements
inside of them so whenever we create a
two-dimensional array like this we
always have to specify
the number of elements and then the
number of elements inside each array so
in our case we're going to have one two
three elements in the array
and each array has two elements inside
of it so it's gonna look like that so we
would say three
and then two and that's basically how we
create it so now let's talk about
accessing these elements so i'm gonna
create a little print statement here
and we're gonna print out some of this
stuff so i'm going to
say percent d and i'm going to show you
guys how we can access individual
elements so basically i'm going to say
nums and let's say that i wanted to
access this top left element this one
the first thing i want to do is specify
the index where uh
the value that i want to access is
stored so like this would be index
position zero this would be index
position one this would be index
position two so we're gonna say zero
and then i want to specify the index
position of the individual element
inside of zero so i could say like this
is element zero this is element one so
why don't we access element zero
so i print out nums zero zero and this
is going to print out that number it's
coming out it's going to print out that
one for us you can see over here we get
that one
so let's try a different one let's try
to grab this 4 right here so this is
going to be at index position
1
and then one so this would be at one one
and now we should get that four let's
see yeah cool so we get the four
all right so that's basically how we can
access elements inside of these arrays
and also just want to point out that um
if i didn't want to give this an initial
value i could just like put a semicolon
here and i could just like manually
define each index location so i could
say like 0 0 is equal to 7 or something
i i like i don't have to give it a um
a value like right up front although in
our case let's just do that because it's
a lot easier
all right so we have our nums array and
we figured out how we can print out the
elements
so now i want to talk to you guys about
another concept which is called a nested
for loop and you guys will see in a
second why i'm teaching this alongside
2d arrays
but a nested for loop is a situation
where we have a for loop
and inside of that for loop we have
another loop so i'm going to show you
guys this really quick let's say we
create a for loop i'm going to create
two variables over here in i and in j
and i don't know if i've showed you guys
this in the course yet but if i want to
just like declare two variables i can
just say i comma j and that'll declare
both variables i'm not giving them
actual values yet we're going to do that
inside these for loops so i want to show
you guys how we can use a nested for
loop in order to print out all of the
elements inside of this two-dimensional
array so i'm going to say 4
i is equal to 0
and we're going to keep looping as long
as i is less than 3
and the reason i'm saying 3 here is
because that's how many elements are
inside of this nums array so i'm going
to keep looping as long as i is less
than 3 and then i'm going to say i plus
plus
now inside of these curly brackets i
want to create another loop so
every time we go through this one
iteration of this top loop we're gonna
fully execute through another loop so
i'm gonna say
four
j is equal to zero
j is less than two
and the reason i'm saying two here is
because that's how many elements are
inside each array
inside of the nums array and you guys
will see in a second why uh
this is gonna work and then i'm gonna
say j plus plus so now i'm gonna make
some more open and close curly brackets
and down here i'm going to actually be
able to print out all of the elements
inside of this array so i'm going to go
ahead and do that
i'm just going to say printf
and we're going to be printing out an
integer because these are all integers
and we're going to be printing out nums
and i'm going to print out nums i
and j
so whatever the value of i is and
whatever the value of j is that's the
index position inside of nums that we're
going to print out and now just so this
is formatted a little bit better why
don't we put a
comma
right there and then i'm also going to
put another print f over here that's
just going to print out a new line
and you'll notice that this printf is
outside of this inner for loop so i'm
going to run this program we're going to
see what it does you guys will see
exactly what's happening and then i'll
sort of walk you through a little bit
more
what is going on so
let's run this program
and you'll see over here when we ran the
program
we're basically getting this entire 2d
array printed out so i'm printed out 1 2
3 4 six so let's talk about why that
happens
over here i'm saying four i's equal to
zero i is less than three i plus plus so
i'm going through this particular for
loop three times i'm gonna execute all
the code inside of this for loop right
here
three times that's as many times as
there are elements inside of our 2d
array
now every single time i go through this
top loop every single time i go through
it
i'm going to execute
this loop in its entirety so i will loop
through this loop all the way through
i'll go through all of its iterations
and this loop says j is equal to zero j
is less than two
and two over here is how many elements
are inside of each one of these arrays
so this element in the nums array has
one two elements inside of it this
element and the nums array has one two
elements inside of it right that's where
this two is coming from then i'm
incrementing j
and i'm going to print out so i'm saying
printf and i'm printing out nums at
index position i
and index position j so the first time
we go through this for loop i is going
to be equal to zero and remember that
first time we're actually going to be
going through this loop two times so
we're gonna be printing out nums zero
zero and nums 0 1
and then we're coming down here and
printing a new line
the next time we go through this i loop
we're going to come down here and print
nums 1 0 and nums 1 1. finally the third
and final time we're going to print out
nums 2 0 and nums 2 1.
that's basically how this is working so
two dimensional arrays and nested for
loops are a match made in heaven and
there's a lot of situations where you
know besides just looping through 2d
arrays that we're going to use nested
loops but hopefully this gives you a
little bit of a introduction into what
they are and why they're useful
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you guys about accessing memory
addresses in c
now in the c programming language a lot
of times we're going to want to store
different information right and there's
a bunch of different ways that we can
store information we can use things like
variables we could use arrays we could
use structs but the basic point is that
whenever we're using c we're going to
want to keep track of and maintain
a bunch of different pieces of
information and one of the easiest ways
to do that is by creating variables so
down here you'll notice that i have a
bunch of variables i have this integer
called age and it just has the value of
30 we have this double gpa 3.4 and we
have this character grade and it has the
value of the a character i have a bunch
of different variables in my program and
it allows me to keep track of data
really easily and i can use these to you
know maintain and i can even modify
these different informations variables
are great but i want to talk to you guys
a little bit about how these work in the
actual physical memory of our computer
so whenever i create a variable for
example when i create a variable called
age and i give it a value of 30
this value 30 actually gets stored on
our computer
so all computers have memory so a lot of
times you'll hear people refer to this
as ram it's called random access memory
and basically ram is the memory that
your computer is going to use when it's
running programs so for example if i was
to run this c program my computer would
use ram it would use that memory in
order to store and keep track of all
this different information
right so when i create a variable like
int age c is actually going to store
this value 30 at a specific memory
location so it's going to take that
value 30 and it's going to store it
somewhere in ram right when i create
this double called gpa c is going to
take this value 3.4 and it's going to
store it inside of the physical memory
on our computer when i create this grade
c is going to store this character and
the physical memory
in our computer now here's the thing
when i create these variables i give
them descriptive names right so i gave
this a descriptive name age so i know
what's stored inside of it right and
when i want to access this value i can
just refer to the name right i can just
refer to age i could modify it i could
print it out i could do something else
to it right i can do whatever i want
with it and the way that i can access
this variable in other words the way
that i can access the value 30 is just
by referring to the name of the variable
same goes down here if i wanted to
access the grade right if i wanted to
access this capital a i could just refer
to the name of the variable but again
here's the thing all of this information
is stored in our physical memory
somewhere and so whenever c needs to
access that information whenever our
computer needs to access this value 30
or this value 3.4
it's actually going to refer to a
specific memory address right so when i
want to access this variable age i can
just type out age and then i can use
this variable
but when c wants to refer to this value
it's not actually using age it's going
to use the memory address where this
value is stored inside of our physical
memory so all of these values are stored
inside of a physical address
in our memory so all of these values
have an address where they're stored in
memory and when c needs to access them
it can use that address
so i'm going to show you guys how we can
access that address how we can print out
the address onto the screen and
basically just wanted to give you guys
an introduction into what memory
addresses were so
down here i'm going to say printf
and i'm going to show you guys how i can
actually print out the physical memory
address where each one of these values
is stored on our computer
so down here if i want to print out a
memory address i need to use a percent
sign and a p
so normally if i was just going to print
out like a number i could say like
percent d or i could say percent c for a
character
when we want to print out a physical
memory address we're going to say
percent
p
and this actually stands for pointer
we're not going to talk about pointers
in this tutorial we're just going to
talk about memory addresses but just
know that you need to say percent p
and now i'm going to type out the name
of the variable whose memory i want to
access so i'm going to access the memory
address of age
and before the variable i'm just going
to say ampersand
so i'm going to make an ampersand age
and i'm going to say percent p
and now we should be able to print out
the memory address where the variable
age is stored in other words we can
print out the memory address where this
value 30 is stored so let's go ahead and
run our program
and you'll see over here we're getting
this number so i'm getting this number
zero zero six zero ff zero zero so this
would be like a hexadecimal number i
guess it's not technically a number it's
like i think it's hexadecimals but
basically this is the physical memory
address where the value of 30 is stored
in other words it's the place where c
stored the value inside of this age
variable i could do the same thing for
these other variables so actually why
don't i format this a little bit i'm
going to say here age
and then i'm going to make a new line
and we're just going to say gpa
and again i'm going to print out another
one of these addresses and we'll do one
for grade
and we'll print out the address so now i
can just come over here and i can sort
of modify this a little bit so i can
just say
gpa
and
grade and you'll notice for each of
these i'm using this ampersand before i
type out the name of the variable so now
when we run our program we should get a
nice little list of all of these
variables and their corresponding
addresses so you'll see over here
we have age and it's stored at memory
address 0060 ffoc
gpa is stored at this memory address and
grade is stored at this memory address
so if you were to like go into our
computer or go into my computer and go
to memory address
0060 ff0c that's actually going to store
the value of 30. it's going to store the
value that's inside of that age variable
if you were to go to this memory address
you would see the value inside of gpa if
you're going to this memory address you
would see the letter which was a capital
a
so basically all of these variables are
stored at different memory addresses
when i want to access the information in
the variable i can just refer to the
variable's name so i could say a age or
i could say gpa but when c wants to
access the information in the variable
it has to use these addresses so c would
use this address c would use this
address and this address
i can just use the variable names and
that's why c is awesome because it
allows us to do stuff like that but
when c and when our computer wants to
access these values it has to use these
memory addresses and so that's why these
are useful
and when we're programming in c it can
actually be pretty useful to be able to
know the addresses like the actual
physical addresses of these certain
variables in memory so a lot of times in
c when we want to work with these
variables we can just refer to them by
name and we can do all sorts of stuff
with them we can access them we can
modify them
but
in other circumstances we're not just
going to want to be able to access the
value we're also going to want to be
able to access their physical memory
address in other words we're going to
want to be able to know like what that
address is and we can use that for a
bunch of stuff and in future tutorials
i'm going to talk about why that can be
useful but for now i really just wanted
to kind of give you guys an overview of
what memory addresses are how we're
using them in our program and how we can
print them out so again
i just use this ampersand and then i
type the name of the variable and i use
this percent p to print it out
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about pointers in c
now a pointer is basically just a type
of data that we can use inside of our
programs so up until this point in the
course we've been using a bunch of
different types of data right we've been
using things like integers and an
integer is just a whole number we've
been using things like doubles and a
double is a decimal number we've been
using chars and a char is basically just
a character and now i want to introduce
you guys to another type of data which
is called a pointer and a pointer is
basically just a memory address and a
memory address basically refers to a
you know a physical address inside of
the memory of our computer where we're
storing a value right and i think
pointers tend to confuse a lot of people
who learn about them and this is sort of
one of those topics and see that
everybody dreads because it's you know
traditionally very confusing to
understand but actually pointers are
extremely simple and the problem is that
they just get over complicated so what i
want you guys to do is i just want you
guys to think of a pointer as a type of
data that's all it is it's just a type
of data that we can work with in our
programs it doesn't have to be any more
complicated than that right i can work
with an integer in my program an integer
is a whole number right i can work with
a double in my program a double is a
decimal number i can work with a char in
my program a char is just a character
i can work with a pointer in my program
a pointer is just a memory address
that's it a pointer is just another type
of data that i can use and i can work
with
inside of my programs and it just
happens to be a memory address inside of
the memory or the ram
in our computers that's that's all it is
it's very simple people over complicate
pointers and they don't have to be over
complicated because it's just another
type of data just like an integer or a
double but instead of being like a whole
number or a decimal number it's a memory
address so hopefully that makes sense
and i hope that you guys don't uh try to
overcomplicate this too much because it
doesn't have to be
so down here in my program i have an
integer that i've created and it's
called age so i just said in age
and inside of this integer age i'm
storing a whole number i'm storing an
integer right 30. and if you've been
following along with this course in the
last tutorial we talked about memory
addresses and we talked about how
all of these variables are actually
storing these values at physical
addresses on our computer's memory so
down here i have this print statement
and i'm just printing out ages memory
address
and i'm using this percent p
and i'm just printing out ampersand age
and we talked about how this ampersand
when i put this in front of the variable
basically it's going to give me the
physical address in memory where this
variable in other words where this
30 value is stored so if i run this
program you guys will see over here it
says ages memory address and it's this
hexadecimal number right this is the
physical memory address
of
the age variable what did we just talk
about before remember what i told you
pointers are
memory addresses that's what they are
it's a type of data a pointer is a type
of data in our program
and it's a memory address right when i
use this ampersand and i type out the
name of a variable this is giving me the
memory address right i'm able to print
out the memory address so really this is
a pointer
this is a type of data in our program
that is a memory address just like an
integer is a type of data that's a whole
number and a double is a type of data
that's a decimal number and a char is a
type of data that's a character a
pointer is a type of data that's a
memory address and this right here this
guy right here is a pointer so it's just
the memory address of the age variable
that's it and when i want to print out a
pointer i can use this percent p
and it'll allow me to print it out onto
the screen and everyone's happy so
essentially what i'm doing here is i'm
printing out a pointer when i say
percent p
i'm telling this printf function that i
want to print out a pointer and then i
give it a pointer over here i give it a
physical memory address that's what a
pointer is now we understand and
hopefully you understand that a pointer
is just a type of data right it's just a
memory address
and we can access the memory addresses
of specific variables by using this
ampersand and then typing out the name
of the variable and that can be pretty
useful now that we understand that i
want to show you guys how we can work
with these pointers so over here i have
an integer variable called age
and this integer variable is storing an
integer value 30.
i'm going to say that one more time i
have an integer variable and this
integer variable is storing an integer
value 30. i could also create a double
variable so i could create a double
called gpa
and inside of this double variable i
could store a double value like 3.4
i could also create a char variable
called grade and inside of this char
variable i could store a character a
i could also create a pointer variable
and inside of that pointer variable i
could store a
pointer okay so just like i stored a
character inside of this character
variable and i stored a double inside of
this double variable i could store a
pointer
inside of a pointer variable so we can
actually store these pointers inside of
a pointer variable now here's where this
is going to get a little bit tricky
when we create a pointer variable
we actually need a physical memory
address right so when i create this um
integer variable like i can just come up
with a number right off the top of my
head right i can just say like 30.
when i create a
double variable i can just store
whatever number i want to store but when
we create a pointer variable remember
we're going to be storing a memory
address and i don't necessarily know any
memory addresses like right off the top
of my head at least i don't know any
meaningful memory addresses so when i
create a pointer variable what i want to
do is store the memory address of a
variable that's already in our program
so i'm going to say that one more time
when i'm creating a pointer variable
inside of that pointer variable i'm
going to store the memory address of a
another variable inside of our program
so let's say that i wanted to create a
pointer that would store the memory
address of this variable over here so
the store the memory adjust of age right
i can create a pointer just like this so
i could say int an asterisk and now i'm
going to give this a name so i'm going
to give this pointer variable a name and
remember this pointer variable is going
to store the memory address of the age
variable and generally when you're
naming a pointer you're going to start
with a lowercase p
and then you're going to type the name
of the variable whose memory address
you're storing in the pointer variable
so i'm going to say ph right because
this pointer variable is storing the
physical memory address of the age
variable now what i want to do is set
this equal to the memory address of the
age variable which we can access using
this ampersand so i could say ampersand
age
so now this pointer variable
is storing the memory address of the age
variable i'm going to do the same thing
down here for this gpa so if i wanted to
create a pointer variable that would
store the memory address of the gpa
variable i could say double asterisks
and i'm just going to say p
gpa just like that and i'm going to set
this equal to the memory address of this
double variable which we can access
using this ampersand and then the name
of the variable like that i'm going to
do the same thing down here for this
character variable so i want to create a
pointer variable which is going to store
the memory address
of the character variable so i'm just
going to say
char
asterisk
a grade and i'm going to set this equal
to ampersand grade okay so that's all
i'm doing right so now
i have this integer variable and i have
this pointer variable which is storing
the memory location or the memory
address of the age variable i have this
double variable which is storing a
double and i have this pointer variable
which is storing a pointer and the
pointer just happens to be the memory
address of the gpa variable i have this
char variable down here
and then i have this pointer variable
which is storing a pointer which just
happens to be
the physical memory address
of the grade variable
in our memory okay and that's basically
all you need to know about pointers to
get started a pointer is just a type of
data it's just a type of information
that we can work with in our programs it
just happens to be memory addresses
right
an integer is a type of data that we can
work with in our programs and it just
happens to be a whole number a double is
a type of data that we can work with in
our programs and it's a decimal number
a char is a type of data that we can
work with in our programs and it's a
character a pointer is a type of data
that we can work with in our programs
and it's a memory address hopefully that
makes sense and just like we create
integer variables and double variables
we can also create
pointer variables the only difference is
whenever we create a pointer variable
we're going to store the memory address
of another variable in our program so so
you'll see over here when i create this
pointer variable i'm using the data type
of the variable whose address i'm
storing so over here when i'm storing
the address of an integer variable i'm
saying int here when i'm storing the
address of a double variable i'm saying
double here when i'm storing the address
of a char variable i'm saying char here
and that's the basics of using pointers
and also creating pointer variables and
storing memory addresses inside of
variables
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about dereferencing pointers in c
now a pointer is basically just a type
of data that we can work with in our
programs that is a memory address so
sometimes in our programs we're going to
want to work with memory addresses we're
going to want to use them in our
programs and do certain things with them
and those memory addresses are basically
called pointers in our programs
and when you de-reference a pointer
essentially what you're doing is you're
going to the memory address of that
pointer and you're grabbing the piece of
information from there right so all
points are our memory addresses and when
we de-reference a pointer we go to that
physical memory address and we get the
information or we get the value that's
stored inside of there so i'm going to
show you guys how we can do that and see
it's actually really easy and
can be pretty useful so
down here i have this integer
and um it's an integer variable and it's
storing the integer value 30 and over
here i have a pointer variable which is
storing the memory address of 30 so it's
throwing the memory address of our age
variable as you can see right here
and down here i'm just printing out this
pointer so i'm printing out ph i'm using
this percent p and i'm just printing it
out to the screen
so why don't we take a look and see what
we get so you'll see over here we just
get this memory address
probably exactly what you expected to
get so over here i want to show you guys
how we can dereference a pointer so this
pointer variable ph is storing the
memory address of this age variable
right so when we printed it out we
basically
were given the physical memory address
where this number 30 was stored so ph is
storing the memory address of 30. it's
storing the memory address where this
value is
inside of our computer's memory
if i want to de-reference a pointer
basically what i'm going to be doing is
i'm going to be going to that actual
physical memory address and grabbing
that piece of information
so the way that i can de-reference a
pointer is by using the asterisk so
when i'm printing this pointer out i can
de-reference it by using this asterisk
but now over here since i'm
dereferencing this pointer i need to
print out a number instead of a pointer
because when i dereference the pointer
this is no longer a pointer this is no
longer a memory address now this is
going to be whatever was stored at the
memory address the pointer was pointing
to so this is going to be an integer
because this pointer
variable was storing the address of an
integer
right so when i dereference it
this is actually going to be an integer
so let me show you guys i'm going to
print out uh or i'm going to run our
program and it should print out
30.
so you'll see there we get a 30. so
basically what's happening here is we're
dereferencing the ph pointer variable
we're dereferencing the ph pointer which
basically means we're going and grabbing
the actual you know physical value
that's stored at the memory address that
the pointer was pointing to and that's
why we get 30.
that's basically what dereferencing is
you know you're you have a pointer you
can de-reference it and you basically
just get the value that it was pointing
to
it's essentially all we're doing so i
want to show you guys how we could do
this um just normally so
for example i have this age variable if
i just typed this out
if i wanted to get the address of this
age variable i could use this ampersand
right that's basically what we did up
here
but what i could do is i could just
dereference this so i can say ampersand
age and then i can put a asterisk here
and this is actually going to
dereference that entire thing
so now when i run my program it's going
to print out 30. so it's not going to
print out the memory address it's just
going to print out 30. so you can see
over here we get 30.
so i could actually do this like as many
times as i want and this will maybe just
illustrate what's happening so i could
put an ampersand here
and now i'm going to get that memory
address again
so you'll see we're getting this memory
address
and i can do the same thing so i could
de-reference this one more time
and
you'll see now we're getting that 30
value again so i mean basically what i'm
doing here is i'm constantly like like
here i'm getting the memory address
where the age variable is stored then
i'm de-referencing it and getting the
value then i'm getting the memory
address again and then i'm
de-referencing it again so
you know hopefully that makes sense when
you de-reference a pointer you're
basically just getting the value that
that pointer is pointing to or you're
getting the value that's stored in the
memory address of the pointer
in this tutorial i'm going to teach you
guys how to write to files and see one
of the cool things we can do in c is we
can actually modify and change and also
create new
files
so in this tutorial i'll just basically
show you guys how to do that we'll talk
about uh creating files writing files
and appending onto files so let's go
ahead and do that down here in my main
function we're actually going to create
a file so i'm going to create a file and
i'm going to store some information
inside of that file
and the way that we can do that is we
can just type out file all in caps just
like that
and essentially what we're doing here is
we're creating a
pointer to a physical file on our
machine so
i'm just going to say file and i'm going
to make an asterisk and i'm just going
to give this a name so i'm just going to
call this f pointer and that'll just
stand for file pointer and i want to set
this equal to
f open
and f open is actually a function that's
going to open a file for us
so inside of these parentheses i'm going
to give this a couple different
parameters
the first parameter is going to be the
name of the file that i want to open so
i'm just going to call this
employees.txt and the second parameter
is going to be a file mode
and a file mode is basically just going
to tell c
what we want to do with the file that
we're going to open and there's a bunch
of different file modes the three most
basic types are r and r stands for read
so if i put r in there it'll mean we
want to read the file w stands for write
so if i put right in there it means i
want to either create a new file or
write over an existing file
and there's also a which stands for
append and that means i want to append
information on the file in this tutorial
we're going to look at w and a
so what i want to do over here is put in
w
and right now employees.txt this file
doesn't actually exist
so what i'm going to do is i'm actually
going to create that file we're going to
put some information inside that file
and then that file gets saved onto my
machine and in order to do that we're
going to need this right mode so it's
just going to be a w
any time that we're opening a file in c
you always want to make sure that you
close the file so over here i'm saying f
open
and down here i want to use another
function called f close and basically
what this is going to do is it's going
to close off the file so it's going to
remove the file from the memory on our
computer and if we do make any changes
it'll kind of like save the file and
everything will just be kind of like
locked in so you always want to make
sure whenever you're working with the
file that you close it and inside of
this f close function we just want to
pass in this f pointer
so i'm just going to say f points are
right there so let's talk about what's
happening here
file is basically just like essentially
like a data type i guess and we're
creating a pointer to a physical file on
our computer so if you remember a
pointer is basically just a memory
address right a pointer is a type of
data that we can use in our programs
it's essentially just a memory address
and this pointer is storing the memory
address of this new employees.txt file
that we're going to create so
essentially what's going to happen is
we're going to create this employees.txt
file and fpointer is going to be
pointing to the memory address of that
file
on our computer so that's essentially
what's happening here
and what i want to do is i actually want
to write some information to
this file so actually let me just show
you guys really quick what's happening
here so without doing anything else just
using this line right here when i run my
program a new file called
employees.txt is going to get created so
over here i'm in my little directory
and if you don't specify an absolute
path or like a relative path for this
it's just going to create it in the
directory that your c file's in so if i
wanted to create this on my c drive i
could say like c
whatever and then like employees.txt and
this will get created in my c drive but
if i don't specify like an absolute path
um or even if i don't specify a relative
path then this is just going to get
created in the same directory as our c
file
and you'll see over here
my main.c file is right here it's in
this folder
so when i run this program let's watch
over here and we can see this
employees.txt file get created so i'm
going to run my program and you'll see
over here that this employees file got
created so if i actually
bring this out a little bit you'll see
it's a text document
it's employees.txt and there's zero
kilobytes inside of this so we haven't
put any information in there but this
file got created so now let's talk about
putting some info into that file inside
this file i'm basically just going to
list out a bunch of like employees that
might work in an office
and the easiest way to write information
to a file is just to say f print f
and this is a special
function in c which actually works a lot
like the printf function so if you've
used the printf function and if you're
following along with this course we've
been using it throughout the entire
course
the printf function basically allows you
to like print information out onto that
console window fprintf is going to allow
us to essentially just write information
to a file i need to give this a couple
parameters the first one is going to be
this file pointer in other words i need
to tell this function you know what it
should be writing to so i'm just going
to say f pointer
and then over here we can just give this
some information so i can just use like
after we put in this file pointer
i can just use this
like i normally would the printf
function so i could just print out like
some employees so i could say like let's
say one of the employees is jim
and we'll put like what they do so like
i could say
salesman
and then we could say actually let's
make a new line
and we'll create another employee pam
and she is the
receptionist and then we can make some
other employees so
so now i have three employees that i'm
going to basically write out to my
employees file so now when i run this
program and we can go over here to this
employees file
you'll see when i open this up that we
have these three lines in here so we
have jim salesman pam receptionist and
oscar accounting so basically i was able
to create this file and write all this
information in the file from down here
just from down here in this program so
that's pretty cool
and i want to show you guys with right
so when i'm using this right
this is actually going to overwrite a
file so for example if i change this
from all this text and i just put like
overwritten in here
now when i run this program
and we open this employees.txt file so
let me reopen this
you'll see it just says overridden so
i've actually overridden all the text
that was in there and that's basically
what happens when we just write to a
file so let's go back to what we had
before i'm just going to run this again
so we have this text
and you'll see now we're back with uh
the employees so let's say that um
inside of this file we wanted to add an
employee onto the end of it so we wanted
to add like a new employee onto this
file right
well i can use something called append
and what append is going to do is it's
going to allow us to append
a new line
onto the end of this file or actually
just append text onto the end of the
file instead of saying w i'm just going
to say a
and you'll notice i'm still keeping
employees.text here and down here inside
of this fprintf i'm just going to print
out
another employee into the file the first
thing i'm going to do is print out a new
line because and actually let me show
you guys this in this employees file
there actually isn't a line after this
last line so the last like position in
this file is over here i can't actually
get onto the line below oscar
so i'm going to want to go ahead and
print a new line and this will move the
next employee on to the next sign we
could say like
kelly and she's going to work in
customer
service so now when i run my program
instead of overriding what was in the
employees.txt file now this is just
going to append this new employee onto
the file so i'll come up here run the
program
and let's open this employees file and
you'll see now we have another entry
kelly from customer service so when we
write a file um
we either create a new file and add
content onto it or we just overwrite the
content in the file
at least using this fprintf function and
when we append we're just appending
information onto the end of the file so
just using those two things i mean you
can
essentially write out any file that you
want um and it's important to note that
you can write more than just text files
so i could write like an html file or i
could write like a css file um
you could write really i mean any type
of file that you'd want and
that's basically how we can write to a
file and append to the end of a file
in this tutorial i'm going to teach you
guys how to read the information from a
file in c in the last tutorial we talked
about writing to file so we looked at
how we could create a file overwrite a
file and append information onto a file
in this tutorial i'm going to show you
guys how you can read information from a
file
so down here you'll notice that i have
my file pointer set up so i just say
file and the asterisks and i called it
fp and remember this is just a pointer
which you know and a pointer is just a
memory address
and it's the memory address of this file
in memory so it's the memory address of
this employees.txt file which we created
in the last tutorial and i'm using this
f open function which basically
opens this file and then i'm specifying
a
file mode we talked about the w file
mode and the a file mode now i want to
talk to you guys about the r file mode
and this stands for read so when i use
the r file mode i'm actually able to
read information from the file and this
can be pretty cool
so in order to read the information in
the file i'm actually going to show you
guys how we can read like the individual
lines of the file so actually first
let's look at the file
this is employees.txt it just has you
know basically a bunch of employees
their names and then what they do
and we're going to be able to read this
file inside of our program so the first
thing i want to do is create a variable
and i'm going to create this variable up
here before we create the file pointer
and it's just going to be an array of
characters and i'm just going to call it
line
and i'm going to give this an initial
size of 255. so this will be able to
store 255 characters
and then down here
in order to read this file i can
actually read the file one line at a
time
and we can use a special function called
f gets and f gets basically is going to
allow us to read the lines of the file
one by one so i could say f gets and i
need to give this a few different
parameters
the first parameter i need to give it is
a place to store the information that it
gets so this function is going to go and
it's going to read the information from
the file and it's going to store it
somewhere so the first parameter we need
to give this function is where it should
store that information so in our case
we're going to store it inside of that
line variable that we created up there
the second thing we need to give this is
a size and this is basically just going
to be like
the
maximum size that we can read in so i'm
just going to say 255. basically this
number should match this number up here
and then we also want to give it that
file pointer so i'm just going to say
f pointer
and basically what this is going to do
is it's going to read the first line of
the file and it's going to store it
inside of this line variable so if i was
to come down here and say
printf
and printed out a string
and just printed out line now when i
print out a line it's actually going to
be have the value of the first line in
the file so let's run this program
and you'll see over here we're printing
out gym salesman and if you don't
remember that was the first line inside
of that employees dot text
so basically what f gets is doing is
it's reading the first line and another
thing that it's doing is it's moving
this pointer so remember this pointer is
essentially pointing to where the file
is in our memory and whenever we use f
gets this pointer is going to get
incremented so it's basically going to
move past the first line in the file
so if i was to use this again
for example if i said f gets again
when i use this it's gonna store the
value of the first line of the file
inside of line and when i use it again
it's now gonna grab the second line in
the file so if i print this out now
this should actually be storing the
second line in the file so when i run my
program you'll see it's storing the
second line pam receptionist
i could basically do this for all of the
lines in the file so that's basically
how we can use f gets to read the
individual lines inside of a file